oh this is starting it's face reveal
this is the intro
face reveal let's go
hello and welcome to another episode of
trash taste podcast i'm your host for
today gigguk
and today joining me is my usual co-host
the boys hello we're the boys hello and
today we have another special guest
do you want to introduce yourself no
i will introduce you for you this is our
producer maylene
you probably heard her voice or seen her
passing the camera a few times
or seen us shouting at her too shouting
at her or whatever but they're a face
reveal
this is whatever producer looks like
yeah and my videos right yeah you're in
really yeah the yawi cafe you're like
the heavy breathing in the background
i think i think you've been on like all
of our channels right
like the rental mom yeah the rental mom
one and yeah
yeah like on trash taste at least for
the first time yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so do you want to explain what your job
is and what you do
and kind of how you're on the podcast
why you're on the podcast today what's
up with that why are you on here
what are you doing free real estate but
anyways
yeah uh i'm bailey may uh i work at
bookwalker
you've probably seen that on all of
their videos don't forget to use all
their coupon codes i don't have one but
anyways yeah so geeksplus is a company
under katakana and book walker and i
started that
within book walker last year and uh
yeah now i work out yeah i don't even
explain that right
yeah basically it's a nervous mess
the long and the short of it is she's
the reason we're all here now
yeah yeah pretty much she's the reason
why this show even exists yeah
exactly and the reason we invited her
today is because
i thought today we could talk about some
spicy industry news guys
so yeah so if you didn't know this a
small
indie you know indie anime site called
kiss anime
recently went out of business business
yeah business
that's the time of recording this as i'm
recording this and
yeah i guess we just wanted to talk
about that talk about piracy because you
know that that always goes well on the
internet twitter has been a mess
oh my god when is twitter not a mess
yeah oh
god i've seen so many garbage tapes
anime was probably the most notorious
and well-known anime piracy website
for streaming for a while for all not
not anymore not anymore but
i'd say at least three years ago it was
definitely like the site yeah
it was the time and then you know as
somebody who at one point used it it
definitely became a thing of oh we're
using dot
are younow instead of dot com okay
that's a little confusing yeah
and then and then suddenly you had to
like like dispose of a bomb or something
yeah you were like
the pictures yeah the caption got so
[ __ ] complicated that i was i was
like i didn't know how to navigate
it and then it got to a point where any
any anywhere you click
on the website you got an ad yeah it was
it was like trying to navigate
minefields just like where can i click i
was like getting an actual
turn into like sulfur x it was
trigonometry question
you would
it was definitely the most notorious i'd
say overall website among the anime
fandom
and it recently closed its doors and
people seemed very upset about that for
some reason as if there isn't like
500 other websites that have been up one
thing that really confused me is that
why are people
sad yeah i guess who's still using kiss
anime in 2020
come on like i i hate the fact that
i i just joke tweeted being like rip
kiss anime rip broke weaves and it
became my most popular
it's got like 90 000 likes i'm like what
it's my most popular tweet and i hate it
i [ __ ] hate it
but like because yeah i i jokingly said
that in the sense of like
yeah who the [ __ ] uses kiss anime in
2020 and so many people like
relate queen yeah
yeah you turn it out of this broke weebs
i don't understand twitter yeah i know
that's horrible people
like i don't know if you guys got this
but like adding me being like you need
to discuss this it's such big community
news i was like why what do you mean
scythe gets shut down all the time and
then another one pops up like yeah it's
the reason we had like every single
country extension ever
of kiss anime is because they moved to
every [ __ ] country until they i
really have none left
yeah i saw like i i saw kiss anime
having a dot whatever in like
in in things that i've never even seen
like i was like are you i'm like
yeah that's russia right that's right
you know okay i i i don't offend the the
russian fans of trash taste and we have
a russian dog a giant rush
right but i'm sorry i feel i feel very
uneasy when i see that dot
ru yeah my browser i'm like whoa
you know something shady going on if
it's on you love russia though yeah
totally
other things though right not only kiss
sam it's like kiss manga
kiss cartoon cartoon there's a kiss
hentai as well i think yeah i think so
yeah yeah there's actually a kiss hentai
not at all
oh yeah i remember somehow i got onto
kiss cartoon and like family guy was
like the most popular and i just sat
there for a second i'm like
people are pirating family guy like
you know youtube exists all the episodes
isn't
available everywhere do you remember
that phase where they were just like
there was a streaming phase where
family guy episodes would just be like
streamed on youtube and it'll just be
like 24 hour family guys dream
24 hours simpsons street front page of
[ __ ] youtube as well
it's not official is it no no no no no
no it's not official and yet like every
time i'd open youtube they'd just be
like
24 hours a 24 7 stream of the cleveland
show i'm like
and there was like 700 000 people
watching this stream i was just like
what uh yeah but yeah it's it's the same
thing that happened with like hentai
haven right when hentai haven got shut
down
people are like oh yeah where are we
going to watch our hentai now i'm like i
don't know
google that [ __ ] there's literally 700
websites for i felt so out of the loop
because i never used hentai haven and
when everyone was losing their [ __ ] i
was like but why don't you just use like
the website i'm using why don't you just
use every other website
i can't yeah yeah but yeah quite a
question to you melin because you
actually work in the industry so what is
your opinion on kiss anime and it's
shutting down as a whole
from like from like someone on the other
side of the wall
yeah someone someone who like works with
you know the the copyright oh yeah i
work in like the anime side i work more
on like the manga
occasionally like we'll do something
with the anime so i can't really speak
for the anime industry
with like most of the discussion twitter
and like most of the discussion
on our side a lot of it is just
speculation we don't actually know
how much piracy affects the industry you
know what i mean i
don't think i think it can be argued
that there's nothing like concrete stats
right there isn't like
because i don't think any of these
piracy sites are making that [ __ ] public
of like how much money they're
actually because they're making a
disgusting amount on all those kinds of
yes
i mean at one point kiss anime was like
one of the top 100
visited websites on the internet which
is [ __ ] insane that's crazy like
imagine how much money they were making
just from ad revenue of being like
the top probably uh worth it to keep
evading you know
yeah yeah what i mean like exactly i
mean they they made a disgusting amount
of money that they
really shouldn't have been making yeah
because because don't a lot of the
because you know obviously when you
watch something pirated it's not using a
standard
youtube player or like a normal it's
using one of those
really sketchy third-party websites that
hosts like anything
i'm pretty sure those websites as well a
lot of the ones they were using would
pay you
to host files right right like video
files because they wanted their player
to become more
like universal so a lot of these were
also kiss anime at the time
again i'm not sure but from what i
understood they were getting ad revenue
like a lot of it
i imagine because you know you go on
that website and you've got like what
ten [ __ ] ads
asian dating singles in your area
always [ __ ] lois from family guy
being rammed and it's like i'm just
trying to watch anime like what is this
no and that'd be always like these
shitty hentai games that would be
yeah so it would be like advertising i
think one time i was watching
something and just this ad with like
[ __ ] wars
or a game called that and i'm just like
is this for real i
think is this for real right now i think
that's a real game because that's just
sticking out my mind
i want to play [ __ ] wars just from the
[ __ ] name over there i love i love
run to gold
don't you accidentally like click on
those ads sometimes and then once you
click
boom boom all
they were getting paid to host the files
and they were sorry i leaned back i
always [ __ ] do that yeah
yes so okay so they were getting like
double address basically right so
and and then you know people on twitter
which i i disagree with i think you can
uh say okay there is a need for piracy
in some extent
right but then there's people who like
boohoo kiss anime man it's just like
that they're doing the real hard work
it's like are you kidding me it's
probably like four dudes racking in
millions bro why are you feeling
sorry for them what the [ __ ] so wait so
i didn't see like the full story of like
how they got shut down
i mean i i assume they just got shut
down by some dmca claims right
like but see because they've they've had
their thing shut down
several times right yeah they went from
like his anime.com to like.net to like
dot ru
eventually right yeah and and then and
then when that happened there was also
like
not as obviously not as big because i
don't think there were articles about it
but people were definitely making a fuss
of like oh no kiss anime is down and
then two weeks later they're back with
his own url
so that's what i just assumed when i saw
that article i was like oh they'll be
back
i think it's the first time they've put
in like a like a message saying like
yeah it's over
yeah like right now right i think so
yeah yeah
they had a discord who the [ __ ] is in
the kiss anime discord
it was like i love kiss anime so much
i'm going to
join the discourse yeah there's there's
always that argument that people present
where it's like uh what is it gabe
newell said like piracy as a service
problem or something i think it's gone
way past yeah i think so
because the piracy is a service problem
argument always gets brought up and it's
just like
it's a different it's a different
situation with the anime industry
so yeah games is a really different
thing like you ever tried to pirate a
game like that [ __ ] is like
annoying yeah exactly like straight up
just annoying but like one thing i find
unique to anime piracy right
and and even hentai to the same extent
as well
is that in no one in in no other
industry do i see a pirate service
get like the branding power that it does
in anime
it's true like you think okay if you
want to pirate a movie or if you want to
pirate a game where where'd you go
where'd you go for that you probably go
to google right but there's no like
oh yes there's kiss gaming i go to kiss
gaming every day
i would die for kiss game are you part
of the kiss gaming disc downloaded [ __ ]
wars
but like you don't you don't see that in
any other industry and it
and it and it's like i don't know why
it's specifically to like the anime and
manga
and like hentai circles where piracy
just has this
branding power where people will like
gather behind this
this service which is just like any
other pirate service you know what i
mean because i remember
like i think it was right before hentai
haven got shut down as well yeah i
remember they like messaged me
being like hey do you want to promote
like our merch line
and i'm like i'm not promoting a merch
line for a [ __ ] pirating website like
i'm sorry like
that's like if that's like if pirate bay
was like bro holy [ __ ]
we've got like these like actually yeah
no no no no no no like i can say that
because they're gone but like yeah they
they fully did that and and i i remember
i missed a few people just being like
does this
does this seem right like i don't know i
think i'm missing something here i don't
think this is
right you're not the only person but it
wasn't hinter haven oh really it was
kiss anime
really yeah yeah yeah so kiss anime were
going to open like a store
they weren't going to open a store and
they messaged me being like hey do you
want to promote our store
and i'm i was there sitting are these
guys for real
what makes you think you're going to get
away with this you know and they they
had like the
ins they had the an entire store page
that they like linked me to and they had
like they had
obviously it was like official products
that were being sold
unofficially right were they like typing
to you or writing to you in clear
english or was it broken no
it was it was actually clear clear was
it was it in russian
no it was like a proper store and
everything and i'm just like man the
these yeah that's the thing the balls on
this guys the hansa haven store as well
was like
he he had already even made like a
landing page for it and he was like this
is the lineup for the stuff and it was
like t-shirts obviously it wasn't
anything like too
like amazingly well designed but you
know it's just simple stuff like just
the hentai haven logo on a t-shirt or
something and i'm like
uh no and then two weeks later i think
yeah i think it was maybe like
two or three weeks later they got like
that whole thing happened where they got
shot down right sir i i wonder if
it comes from disdain from the major
companies more so than
them because they don't actively brand
anything they don't do anything they
don't have like a
heated funny twitter account right like
yeah like all like kiss anime never did
anything i think it's just because
it's all community i think yeah i think
a lot of the community just does not
like
the you know the big guys which you know
whatever you need to share
too yeah there they are your friend
doesn't have an account and they're new
to anime and you're trying to get to the
anime you'll link them to like a pirate
scene and also it works on
every in every country right yeah yeah
yeah official stuff so like i i do think
there is a space for piracy i mean i
made an entire video on fan subs and how
that was like really really important
for the community and how it helped it
grow
and i will make that argument that i i
do think there is a space where
piracy does did very much did play a
part in helping anime grow especially
abroad but i think it's gotten to the
point now that anime
i i don't know it's it doesn't have that
same effect anymore because anime is now
big enough where everyone knows anime
yeah yeah so i think the you know i
think it's there's still like a lot of
countries
where that kind of need piracy to help
boost boost like anime to make this a
truly global medium
but places like the us and like the uk
and you know
places where you have a lot more
accessibility and the phantom is a bit
bigger
it's like that argument doesn't hold as
much water as it did
[ __ ] 10 years ago or something like
that yeah i mean i mean 10 years ago i
mean
even further beyond that right the whole
western community
came from piracy right because you had
to get like a bootleg like
v8 jet v why i say h like that
vhs tape right you had to get a bootleg
one that was all shared around it was
all piracy but obviously like you said
it's growing out of that and i guess
some people want to hold on to that and
argue that i think that's the biggest
problem though right is that
a lot of the a lot of the discussion
that revolves especially around
anime piracy is like both sides of the
argument is
very very much like situated on both
sides of the spectrum right it's like
you either
hard agree that piracy and anime is bad
or you
hard disagree like yeah there's very
rarely any people who are kind of like
there's benefits but there's also
demerits to it because
i'm definitely someone who's in the
middle yeah i'm like yeah it's
it's hard for me to get involved in like
any discussion on twitter because
you if you say anything you play they
even either put you on one side or the
other
yeah you're either like like hard into
piracy or you're like a [ __ ]
crunchyroll in funimation or book walker
yeah like right
filthy booklets no i work at book
walkers like
i i know i probably shouldn't say this
but i'm in between like
yeah yeah the only reason like i'm
technically in this industry or i got
interested was because
there were pirate sites right yeah i got
you into it right yeah yeah and i got
into it
and i mean now there's just so many
subtitles available
yeah many platforms there's really no
excuse but you know if
you want to see something fast and in
low quality and maybe the translations
aren't because it's stuck in netflix
uh yeah one one one question one
question i always had about
you know on the japanese side of things
is that how aware
are the japanese companies of all these
pirate sites very aware
are they very aware yeah i've talked
it feels very japanese they're like we
don't care i sleep oh you're pirating
our anime
i'm woke like no they care they're very
strict especially
like not talking about like websites but
for example youtube
yeah yeah we know yeah yeah yeah fair
use fair use is another thing in japan
responses right if we want to show just
a screenshot of an anime
if if they're sponsoring it they're like
they'll bring that up they're like do
you have rights to show the screenshot
and it's
like it doesn't matter if they have a
problem like because i guess the youtube
mentality is right if it's a problem
they'll let us know
right yeah they'll take without
copywriters right whatever we'll fight
it or if it's if it's really unfair and
i've just uploaded a 10 minute family
guy
or 24-hour family guy stream yeah i
probably shouldn't be doing it yeah
right but
most of the time it's like if they have
a problem that they can come and tell us
yeah right
but yeah i feel like they're very much a
risk-averse mindset where it's like just
don't ever
allow that situation to happen yeah so
like on the bookwalker side of things
how
how much of an effect do you guys see on
piracy on like on like your side of
things
and is it how like how do you go about
justifying that as well
that's a that's a that's a toughy thing
that's a hell of a question i mean if
you don't have an answer that's fine
yeah i don't really have like a
huge answer well book walker is
technically very
new and right despite it being
around for almost five years
when a pirate site goes down we don't
see that much
of effect because our users they're
the people who have been like coming to
our store like
every month are the type of people who
want to support the industry
yeah people who have been stealing for
years and they don't have money even if
the site goes down they're not going to
come to
our store right like that's like in the
west but in japan there's this site
called
or used to be a site you probably you
know it joey mangamura yeah
when it went down like there was a huge
increase in sales
was basically like the kissmonger of
japan it was one of the biggest manga
pirating sites
and that got like properly shut down
like the founders were like straight up
charged and went to jail and everything
yeah
yeah oh wow yeah because a similar thing
happened to the uh
to a big western app recently which was
manga
that got shut down did they not they
like
pivoted yeah and shot it they shut down
the app in many ways and then we're like
hey we have other stuff check it out
yeah like so like don't are you
basically yeah
like after they shut down did you see
any change or door increase in
traffic or sales or anything on your
side not so
much i would say i mean because they
also like i don't know share this okay
book walker's like
more popular for light novel readers
right and usually pirate sides
have mongols when they want to read
something
like i don't know manga or whatever and
they want to pirate it they're going to
stick to other pirate sides is there any
no
noticeable difference between the
spending habits of westerners and
japanese
on manga anything that like you're
allowed to tell us
because i think the general stereotype
is that the western audience is very
[ __ ] stingy extremely stingy
yeah i i remember it because i think i
had this mindset of i'm not paying for
any media like when i was like 13 right
grew up with just like parroting
everything yeah yeah yeah exactly and
then
i think once you take that step of
paying for media i think you don't go
back
because you're like whoa that was really
easy that's the thing it's like
i always feel i always feel piracy yes
i always feel that's why i've always
said like piracy isn't exactly a bad
thing because i feel it's just a
stepping stone towards
getting into the actual family yeah and
then once you're mature enough and
you've
you know made your own money and whatnot
yeah i do think most of the time not
saying it all the time
it's normally the younger one to a die
hard like piracy and it's like yeah okay
that normally comes from
no having no income at all yeah yeah
yeah right you know
maybe your parents give you like 10
bucks a month or something i don't know
you can't spend that on
yeah you're not spending that on the
line no right like no one's going to do
that
like it makes sense that then that you
hopefully transition into it and
you know when you get older and you get
more monkey brained like myself it it
becomes
really [ __ ] annoying when you're
looking for 10 plus minutes to just find
a link to watch what you want to watch
yeah yeah and i'm like i will i will
throw 10 bucks to make this problem go
away yeah
i am just i want to watch it comfortably
and just yeah
reliably right then yeah but then
there's people who argue like oh yeah
well
there isn't the good services to watch
anime every month there is it's just
most of the time people don't want to
admit that like yeah even using
crunchyroll here in japan it's a bit of
a pain because i have to use a vpn
it's still less annoying than going to
kiss anime
opening up five [ __ ] tabs pressing
pause six times before all the ads
you all know this right you know you've
used too many websites when you know
you're like all right how many clicks do
i have to how many times you have to
press play
before it actually plays it's three
times three is the magic number right
it's always
three and then you you better [ __ ]
hope to god you have to pause that [ __ ]
because if you pause that [ __ ] and you
want to press play again
you know you got more pop no because i
will i always want to skip the anime
opening and i know
to skip the anime opening [ __ ] pause
the cost you pay is three extra clicks
just because you want to skip the anime
opening sometimes you completely [ __ ]
the buffering and you've got to reel
over the whole thing
and then before and then
you cannot allow this thing to play you
need to skip to a woman at 30 before it
even allows you to pop it off
it might [ __ ] up and you cannot rebuffer
so i just want to avoid that dance
and that's exactly why i stopped using
his anime like four years ago right
because i'm just like i'm
i'm better than this i don't want to go
through this torture like and chromecast
exists now right yeah
no i want to cast that [ __ ] i just i
just want to press one button it goes on
my tv
you can't do that with pirate sites yeah
you know what i mean
some of them you can but it doesn't
always work like sometimes you'll be
watching it and you'll be like okay cool
episode one
allows me to chromecast yeah episode two
none of these these web players on the
mirrors allow you to chromecast then
you're like
[ __ ] sake it's the youtube anime like
part seven is missing problems
all over again right but you have to
like it's like do i just cave in
and like just watch this on my phone and
just be really annoyed for 20 minutes or
do i you know and
that happens to me i have to do that
because obviously sometimes control
doesn't
have it and then there's no other way
for me to get it and it's on netflix
[ __ ] netflix japan not having english
subtitles yeah i
[ __ ] hate that i've not been able to
watch so many shows that should be
available to me because
yeah yeah you put the netflix to you uk
boom it has english subtitles
why can't you just put the subtitles on
the japanese netflix you have the
subtitles
why would you not offer them i don't
have that problem
if you wait a few months
if you wait a few months uh the
subtitles do get on
like i'll just wait a few months no
becky they were there straight away
were they yeah yeah yeah it was there
yeah it's just you
it's [ __ ] rolling a dice where the
netflix will put english subtitles on it
it's like oh maybe it will maybe i'll
i'm gonna
go and watch this anime yeah no
subtitles [ __ ]
like one one thing i never got about
some of the things like some of the
reactions i see on twitter is you know
you know if you're gonna pirate anime
that's fine i know plenty of people
pirate anime
but there's been this like movement
recently that i've seen where people are
just like
[ __ ] like proud of this [ __ ] like
right like you should pirate anime that
helps everything that that
that helps the industry and i'm like bro
like i get it you want a pirate anime
okay
like i i do it we all everyone [ __ ]
does it you know yeah but there's
there's a difference between
yeah okay yeah you know i i watch some
of my shows pirated too yeah i stand up
for this [ __ ]
i'm gonna defend this [ __ ] you know that
i don't get that
i think what it's maybe come from i
don't know just
i'm speculating here is that like you
get so many influences and people in the
industry who like actively shame people
who admit that they pirate
yeah and even us right what are you
talking about saying that we admit that
we pirate it's pretty risky move right
like
crunchyroll easy turn around be like
we're never working with you again right
like thank you for the free account by
the way i love it
i do actually use my crunchyroll account
thank you miles you're at i love you
but you know just us mentioning that we
pirate right
yeah maybe there's some other youtubers
out there that would be like how dare
you admit that you pirate you should be
a
uh uh you know a role model to those
yeah but that's like saying like you
know oh no i didn't drink until i turned
18. i was like [ __ ]
everyone drinks before they turn yeah
but you're not a 16 year old you're not
there as a 16 year old being like
guys i'm getting [ __ ] hammered in the
middle of the [ __ ] city you know
i'm proud to defy the law yeah yeah i
had alcohol before i was 18 which is the
legal drinking age in the uk yeah but
i wasn't there shouting it out for every
[ __ ] parent to see
right i wasn't there in the [ __ ] off
license being like hey by the way
i'm 16. sell me your [ __ ] alcohol i'm
doing something illegal
i think it's so much more approachable
for viewers and people who watch us and
especially people in the industry to
admit like hey at one point i
you know i did pirate but i i even now i
still pirate when i what's important is
the word did yeah right
yeah it's that you did pirate but you
don't actively
yeah i only rely on pirating now if i
have a choice to pay and get it done
easily i will yes i'm lazy and that's
what i'll do but yeah
you know i think having this mindset of
you can never admit that you pirated you
can never speak no that's
not any merits like i feel like it just
actively pushes people away from having
any form of constructive like argument
because i think i think in in i think
actually most people would
fit somewhere in the middle i think so i
think but the only takes we see on
twitter
is either like people actively like
slut-shaming piracy or something like
that
or just ordering on pirates or just on
piracy and i'm like
neither of these are correct and i don't
know why these are the only takes i see
on twitter
i think as well one thing that drives a
lot of people away especially from
the bigger figures like the a lot of the
voice actors and all the people in the
industry is that
like just actively like saying like you
know you are wrong i am in this industry
i know better than you although okay
there is a sense of that right you are
in the industry so maybe you have a
bit more of a point but you know as far
as a voice actor goes it's like
you have no [ __ ] saying what happens
you're you're doing a job like you're
doing a service like as far as you're
concerned you're just in the show and
that's where you're like
commitments end you've no bearing on the
shirt yeah you're not in the industry oh
no right right and
i think you know it's it's i think that
a lot of these voice actors are also
forced then to like you can't because
the way the industry works you can't
like you can't be
your friend no you're wrong because if
your scene is problematic like no it's
serious like if you're saying it's
problematic it's like oh well maybe a
director won't hire you because
you're not being a bit of a dick on
twitter right right you don't support
you said anime piracy was uh good
and we you know we wanted to hire you
but yeah you know you've got a partner i
mean i mean
i think a lot of people don't realize
that just actively shaming people
and like it's just we'll just push them
away to the other side
and it doesn't work by saying hey you
you know you shouldn't pirate this is a
bad thing even though like
technically you know it is you know yeah
but that you know it that doesn't mean
that
people don't buy it for like a reason
yeah as weird as it is to say it's like
a really
weird form of gatekeeping almost it's
almost like a reverse gatekeeping where
it's like
if you if you pirate then you're not a
real anime fan you really don't support
the industry and it's like
no you you can you can eventually get to
that point but you have to start
somewhere right yeah and if piracy is
your only option
then piracy is your only option yes i
saw like it was like a tweet i don't
know there was one of the takes that was
like oh it's not available in your
country tough it wasn't made for you and
it's like whoa
it's like yeah okay no one has right to
anything right but yeah also if you
can't get it legally and you're a fan of
the stuff like yeah [ __ ] it
who cares pirate that [ __ ] there's no
way for you to pay for it like what why
why i don't understand why this is such
a no you can't there was another [ __ ]
horrible take which was like anime
is a luxury you remember that one oh
yeah yeah we saw like this like list of
[ __ ] like horrible arguments towards
piracy it was like anime is a luxury and
you you should be
you you should you should really like
you know be proven lucky that you even
get the chance to watch any of this
stuff i'm like
yeah it's just a [ __ ] cartoon bro
i've like chill i like i know some
people who like work like two jobs have
no [ __ ] money
and like yeah they can't afford the like
three subscriptions they need to watch
all the shows they want
yeah dude kick back and relax you
deserve that [ __ ] you've been working
hard man
i don't i don't give a [ __ ] i would if
someone is broke as [ __ ] i would not
shame them
no i don't care like i think that we can
all agree that the probably the worst
take is the
the whole anime merch take right oh god
like the i buy anime merch therefore i
have the right
to pirate like we think we all buy a lot
of anime merch
yeah yeah used to right i used to buy a
lot
oh okay tell us the reason why yeah why
was that why is it a past tense
the real reason is
it's too much tea in this episode the
tea is being spilled okay but like what
are you
as someone who actually works in the
industry what do you feel about like
that argument of like the i buy anime
merch therefore i have the right to
pirate
kind of i mean you can't use it as a
reason because i think
i don't know how to explain this like
for example
royalties for goods so i've heard from
my
friends in the industry yeah they go to
different
departments it's not always directly to
like
that specific creator right yeah right
so so what so what are you saying like
if you buy if they buy much these the
money still doesn't go back to the
original creator
it does it depends i think on the
contract they had so i've heard
okay so i've heard it's not i'm not in
that i imagine
the bigger of a brand the anime is the
easier is to get a better deal in terms
of royalties and
cuts i imagine yeah i don't know
yeah because because one thing that
always like that always confuses me is
that people think that
i know there's there's there's a lot of
arguments that
that have been made that doing export is
better for supporting the industry than
doing why
and i don't know how much like i don't
know where they're getting this
information from because none of these
people are like working in the industry
so every argument i see on both sides of
things
is a lot a lot of the time just
anecdotal speculation
and just speculation there's no there's
no theory behind it they're just like oh
i mean i feel good
buying merch you know it feels like um
if i buy official merch right yeah
because it's tied to that particular ip
yeah you
you just feel like oh i'm supporting it
i'm i'm helping to spread the love i'm
putting money into something that's
official
so therefore in the back of their head
they're just like yeah that's going to
go back to the creator in some way right
like they're not
doing anything right yeah yeah of course
but is it the best way to support that
particular creator of the ip no not the
best but better than
what is like the so the best way just
legally streaming
paying for the services is that the best
way uh in your opinion
i've heard that the dvds blu-ray dvds
for example
i'm not sure about the us but in japan
buying the blu-ray dvds is the best
yeah yeah yeah that's when they know
yeah because they measure success from
blu-ray sales right that's
when we have that and like the original
uh sources
sale yeah like the manga oh so the manga
and stuff like
that okay that's what i've heard yeah
because i always try to make sure i buy
my manga first hand now like
even if it's like an older series where
i can easily go to like a book off or
something and buy it for 100 yen like i
always just try and go to the bookstore
the firsthand bookstore because like
i've heard that is truly the best way to
support the creator
right i guess because when it's
pre-owned right like like the royalties
don't go
yeah right i mean like two-thirds of my
jojo merch is like pre-owned stuff
that's because it's like
you can't get that stuff because for
some reason it wasn't made for you it
wasn't available at the time
don't deserve it i deserve all the jojo
like yeah i don't know like i spent
thousands of dollars on like yahoo
auction right but none of that goes to
like
because a lot of the time as well like
this merch is like what like a hundred
bucks and then two years later on yahoo
auction it's 300 bucks
and someone made a nice profit i mean
good for that iraqis definitely not
seeing that profit right yeah
i mean you know the only thing that i've
bought that's like brand new
is probably the jump store stuff that we
both bought
like because uh the jojo exhibition
museum was cancelled
and normally you have to go to the jojo
exhibition to get the stuff but they
were like hey you can just order it
online so i ordered like the suits
the suits as well i got it but the thing
is with the suits right that's
bandai collaboration with perfect suit
factory oh yeah so there's like two
companies
that are making this thing before yeah
they're taking most of it
so like these 500 suits how many of that
goes to like
you know shonen jump and then are like
like the animators aren't seeing that
[ __ ] right the animators are still
underpaid as [ __ ]
i mean i don't think there's anything we
can do for paid because it's just
japan's salary the average salary
man mike is taking a beating yeah like
in general is low
yeah yeah yeah i mean i i feel like with
animators it's a
like systematic problem with how the
industry works as a whole
that's a whole other camera that's
that's a whole other kind of word that's
also just like
japanese culture yeah yeah that's that's
that's a whole different argument to be
had but
um i think one thing i see with a lot of
like western twitter and western people
is that
i feel like they don't want to support
the industry
mostly because they're not happy with
like some of these bigger companies or
like the image of like say crunchyroll
or funimation
and it's it's it's less of i don't want
to support the industry and more of
i don't want to support these companies
in particular
yeah do you want you don't want to
support the companies that are
representing the industry in my country
right i
i can understand it at times because you
know there's a lot of arguments that
people make like underpinnings
underpinning translators that comes up a
lot and you know you know like last year
like it was like voice actor apocalypse
funimation like there's a lot of reasons
why people might not want to right and
it's
it's tough because it's it's because i
don't think there's a
right or wrong argument but
what i feel sometimes that a lot of
people will won't support the industry
unless like
a perfect system where all the money
they go to goes to this one creator like
they want to
they want a utopian system like like
like a utopian system where like every
creator has a [ __ ] patreon or
something and they can support
any creator they want and how much they
want and that's just not a business
model you know what i mean
yeah and i feel like a lot of people use
that justification to say hey
we're not supporting the creator how i
want to support the creator
um so i'm just not going to support
anything and i feel like there must be
there must be a better way to go about
it than that because there's never going
to be a person i mean
the trigger kind of did the right thing
right like they have a patreon they have
a twitch stream where they do like
patreon
i'm not too sure i think i checked and i
was like i was like that is nowhere near
enough to oh no definitely not it's
it's basically just like a side revenue
for them but at least it's a way that is
will actually go directly to the studio
and is a payment method or a donation
method that
westerners are very familiar with right
so i think it's good to have just an
option to do something like that it's
like hey do you want to directly support
the studio and like you know
has that it's not a studio but like
there are some illustrators oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah definitely but i mean
like yeah i mean that's
really the only thing and barely
anybody's utilizing it right like
i've never heard of a manga artist using
patreon is it like
joking there's like a pride thing in
japan like not wanting to ask people for
money
because like begging is really like not
a thing here i don't know
i mean culturally you're being smarter
yeah like not even homeless people yeah
you don't see yeah homeless people like
just do their own thing yeah like that's
just like all right
[ __ ] you you've never seen him yeah
right yeah because it's not
yeah it's not a thing here like there's
so even the homeless here are respectful
where they're just like no no no no
keep your money yeah they're like i'm
i'm i'm i'm homeless i still have my
prize
yeah yeah exactly it's i think it's just
a different culture
there's a lot of it that comes down to
that though i think in the industry and
how people want it to change it's just
not going to i also i also think a
really big
root of the problem when it comes to at
least the anime industry is that they
truly
even though in my experience having you
know done stuff with a lot of different
studios and
productions and whatnot in anime they're
aware of the western industry
they just don't really give a [ __ ] about
them yeah like it's people say they care
they don't know how it's not their first
priority though their first priority is
always the japanese market right
and that's and that's how they measure
their success i mean of course you know
i'm sure all of these studios now it's
2020 right like i think most of them are
aware now that there are way more
western fans
who are into their anime than there will
ever be japanese fans right
but china alone right yeah or just
south east asia even all the mobile
games coming out for china yeah
even if you just look at southeast asia
right that's more people just in general
who will watch the anime and enjoy the
anime and be willing to spend the money
on it but
because the japanese anime industry is
so a lot of it is so
old-fashioned and you know thinking just
locally
that they're just like okay we
understand that there are all these
people out here who are probably willing
to pay for our stuff
yeah we just don't know how to do it but
we can't be bothered to figure out how
to i mean
it's culture in general though isn't it
yeah it's just like for example the dvd
and blu-ray
business model is just not going to work
abroad
yeah you know what i mean i mean it can
prop up the anime industry here in japan
and it has for like the longest time
but it took them like how many years to
figure out that people just don't want
to buy dvd
that's like if crunchyroll was like
we're going to open up a blockbuster
tomorrow come on in and
rent your dvd's
you know it's yeah like it's shocking
how many people
in japan do not know streaming services
yeah like even young people
are just are not aware they're like oh
you can you can watch anime on netflix
what
they usually record it on their tv like
when it's
yeah when it's playing on tv yeah but
it's like i'm not staying up till 3am to
watch a [ __ ] rent a girlfriend i've
never seen a place where they like sell
uh crt tv so much
like their crt i mean smash players were
like yes yes
like everyone else is like why the [ __ ]
would i need to see our tv yeah
there's so many those big [ __ ] chunky
ones
like i see so many of them the tv that
you grew up with like the giant like the
[ __ ] brick of a t
the thick boys i was in uh akihabara and
it was like a brand new electronics
store there was like lcd
like thin tvs and there's a whole
section for crt
tvs and i'm like who the [ __ ] is buying
this
genuinely who the [ __ ] is buying crt tv
because like they're
for smash play except for like the like
the
second-hand store culture here in japan
is [ __ ] on another level because
you go into a secondhand store and they
have they have like [ __ ] laser
laserdiscs
in like pristine pristine conditions i
bought
a [ __ ] like full laserdisc set of
all the episodes of evangelion for like
500 yen i don't even have a laser
display
i was just like holy [ __ ] why why is
this here
why is it such good quality if you love
retro games my god
like they have every single retro game
system
puff you can buy like an and then this
n64 like used like 20 bucks dude i
bought my n64 brand new inbox for like
90
yeah you could get the snes inbox like
50 bucks in stores it's crazy you can
get
like genesis games which are normally
really expensive in the west
super cheap everywhere here yeah sorry
going on tangent just it's crazy
it's great if you like retro games like
what the [ __ ] is this i space out like
half the time
we just talk mad [ __ ] bailey's like yeah
yeah yeah
so like in your guys's opinion then what
can what can be improved in like the
industry and how they approach
you know marketing marketing themselves
to the west and you know
obviously never getting rid of piracy
because i don't think piracy is ever
going to no no
ever going to disappear but how could
you how could he
chill the [ __ ] out that's what i'd like
that's like the one that piece of advice
i wish they would take like just take a
little bit more time like the next five
or ten years it'll probably be much well
i think it's sad right because i think
what would take
one or two years in american companies
right even if you're that right
it's like 10 years in japanese companies
you have to remember it's like an
island and i know i know i know it is i
know but it's so
it's really telling though when like you
know japan is like still stuck in the
80s with like how they run their
businesses sometimes i'm just like it
just doesn't but
again i think it's just every single
thing that's like why are they doing
this
it's just a cultural thing right it
comes back to like it just you know
i definitely think one thing that will
really really help is just
like just having an interest to
listening to
like what the foreign market is doing
right like and
a great start for example is like
working with foreign youtubers like us
for example
yeah because i've i've i've convinced
some companies to be like oh yeah
actually that's a really dumb thing to
do in our company and they stop doing it
and it's it's
worked out for them just because you
know we understand it's really telling
when we understand the foreign market
more than
the actual industry here yeah and we're
not even that
you know highly knowledgeable or like
you know that in-depth
about how the industry works right
exactly we've just been around it and
it's kind of surrounded by it right
i mean you see it time and time again
where a japanese company just uh is like
dead fast and sticking to what they want
to do and not changing i mean if you
even look at like
konami right with like kojima yeah yeah
they kicked kojima out because they
wanted to focus on mobile games and
pachinko and that's all they [ __ ] do
now pachinko yeah and sure it's working
great in japan but
as far as the western like uh community
is concerned konami is a dead [ __ ]
yeah konami died like
you know what i mean konami and i think
capcom's kind of doing the same road
right they made like
the moment capcom axed mega man they
were like they were just dead and then
what was the other game
they brought out recently the top down
shooter that was [ __ ] awful i can't
remember i don't remember i don't even
know that
keep up with them yeah dude i keep up
with all the game news and it's just
embarrassing because it's like
all kinds of dust yeah it's pachinko
yeah these are these companies that were
like
goliath companies and that everybody
knew who capcom and konami was
capcom konami were giants in the nes
series yeah
you couldn't adapt to the generation
even even but even with konami right
when they had kojima like kojima was
steering them in a good job i don't i
don't know
inside politics it looked like i mean he
was pranking like
pt right came out yeah silent hills
hills yeah you know
i mean that's just one really public
occasion right but yeah i mean just
interacting with them we see this kind
of stuff time and time again where it's
like you have like
the perfect idea and they're like no
yeah
i don't know what we're allowed to talk
about but it's like
also hard for them to kind of
try something new because they have no
data to back it up
that's but that's the thing right if no
one's willing to try anything new yeah
nothing happens there's no data for
something that's new
right are we going to talk about the
audio book for example was that we
mentioned that like how like okay so
when we did the audio book the
yellow one yeah plug go buy it um
we were trying to pitch to some of the
companies saying hey would you mind like
helping out with the funding of the
audio because i basically how the
audiobook got made was i put all my
money into it
and i hope that it sells well i make my
money back and it's worth one month
luckily it did one month of my life
right luckily you guys are amazing you
guys bought it and i
mean it was i mean you're so stressed
out that much oh my god i was [ __ ]
losing it dude i was stressing out my
because it's like when you're in charge
of it solely it just takes one person to
not do what they're supposed to do
to ruin everything yeah yeah right and
so shout out to segee man
amazing audio editor he came in clutch
he did an amazing job and it turned out
really well
um we did two one was a test one was a
test it worked out
we proved that it was successful right
so we had the data that this would sell
well
and so we went around pitching to
several different
basically saying hey you're going to get
guaranteed sales with this would you
like
to have the data yeah it was like data
hard evidence yeah this would get you
at least x amount of sales oh i'm sorry
yeah it would get you x amount of sales
you would definitely get a return on the
investment
and none of them wanted to like even
remotely go close right
and what was the reasoning behind that
though yeah what was the reason i can't
remember it was something like they just
didn't think it would work right no
i think it was not that it's just they
didn't want to put their money
into it they didn't want to put their
money into something that
would they had the hard evidence that it
would work yeah and then we
i just decided because originally we
were going to publishers and being like
hey
do you know how we'll choose one of your
books book walker supported that one too
so it's like book walker in you
supporting that project yeah yeah both
of us right like we have a track record
that i've done it
and but none of these companies were
willing to like even give it a shot like
i didn't even need that much right like
i produced the audiobook for like two
thousand dollars which is a lot less
than like i mean that also
one month of time for one time yeah yeah
yeah doing it non-stop we made a video
about it like
very like they were getting an insane
deal right yeah and none of them wanted
to do it
and then we just chose one we chose we
just chose i just chose a book that i
like
did it and got up it's been like what
like number one like
number one every month a top ten now
it's yeah like top top five top three
that's a flex right there every month
since it came out and it's just like
it's so frustrating
wanting to do these bigger projects and
none of these japanese companies just
wanting to even give a chance well
that's just called bad [ __ ] business
we know that it works right we know that
we can make this work and it's so
frustrating having to work with these
companies
i've always been curious how did you
convince book walker
a japanese company to start to start
working with like western youtubers
because
i remember that like yeah i want to know
how that works the first the first time
yeah joey was the first one but i think
book walker was the first japanese
company
yeah ever contacted me i think like or
still now one of the only ones
that i've like ever gone out and
contacted contacted us yeah without
bookwalker yeah yeah yeah and
that was your idea right yeah so so how
did you convince them to do that
i mean before uh i guess using youtubers
that's a bad way i'm sorry before
collaborating there we go get
i was doing marketing for them and i
guess i still was i'm not in book walker
now but i've tried so many things i've
done
like sns ads or collaborations with
cosplayers or uh fan art
artists right okay and i worked with
anime clubs
and i think oh yeah i worked with anime
clubs wow because they had movement
movie nights or they want to have
i don't know mom so you sponsor the
movie nights yeah yeah okay
you paid them we gave them like free
books
to say oh okay maybe you guys should
read it because the idea was they're
going to be the ambassador of their
community
right and if you give them like free
manga they'll check it out and then
they'll give it to their friends
yeah yeah yeah if only there was some
way to just reach a ton of people
pretty easily like the internet or
something yeah i actually did it yeah so
i was like
around like like what's bigger than an
anime club what's bigger than
we gotta think bigger yeah
so i didn't even know that anime youtube
was a thing i knew
like anime music videos um very illegal
stuff
yeah in their eyes i've made anime music
videos
fired from books no
uh but yeah so i just knew about that
type of like
anime youtube but then i was a big
follower of a lot of
like japanese vloggers not japanese ones
japan vloggers
and then joey appeared in one of the
videos of
the person that i was watching and i was
like this person's called anime man
man oh this is oh this this could hmm
that's from
your brain marketing right so so you
didn't even know he was an anime
youtuber if he wasn't called the anime
man you would you wouldn't have like
looked into it
right now i think you weren't even
talking about
anime if i wasn't a j vlogger i think it
was like sharla's
video sharla in japan oh yeah yeah i
mean if i'm collabing with j vloggers
i'm not
going to talk about like i can talk
about other things as well
yeah i i don't think i was talking about
anime at that point
i don't remember i think you were like
mixing drinks in a royal host
oh yeah something something maybe i
don't know yeah i go
not google do you i just click your
videos and then i
just started watching and i was like
what there's people that review anime
why would anyone want to watch
that
i hate reading i hate reading people's
comments
like for example crunchyroll videos on
the bottom comments yeah yeah yeah
i hate reading them yeah yeah yeah
because you know they might not like the
same character whatever yeah
i don't want people to say they don't
like what i like yeah maybe some garbage
opinion
dubs are better than subs or something
and i was like
i don't agree but let's see if he like
likes manga
and then i emailed and i was like oh
not gonna lie the first time i got your
email and
it said like from like you know it was
like color color yeah
i was just like whoa fishy i think this
might be fish i think this might be a
fishing email
i actually thought the same because i
remember the first time you emailed me
immediate delete because i'm just like
there's no way there's no way this is
legit
there's no way this is legit i did email
you and then i asked joey's like
you know i think this other anime tuber
is not at all
cause i was like there's no way catacow
was emailing me like that
like i don't know one cuddle color and
it's like the anime company
because book walker is actually like a
subsidiary it's not like
right yeah no one knows at that time
yeah yeah because i'd never heard a book
walker i've ever seen a cowboy
like what is what is this shady company
what is this shady company that's using
caterpillar's name i'm like there's no
way this
is legitimately like i i got the email
because i was living in australia still
at the time i'm pretty sure oh no i was
trying to move here it was like
six months yeah yeah yeah i was already
in japan that's right and i remember
like i sent that email like
i forwarded to my mom and dad just to be
like english
does this look legit like i don't i'm
really scared to remind you
why is it in english and why is like the
name like she doesn't sound japanese
southeast asians and i was like well you
know i'll give it a go if it ends up
being a fish
whatever yeah that was the best email i
ever sent because i asked you to come to
the office too
that's right that's right yeah and then
when you gave me the address and i
looked it up on google maps i'm like
okay this is legit
yeah because it's actually in one of the
colleges yeah yeah yeah exactly
i think i heard was it true that like
katakawa just didn't like they wanted to
meet
the youtuber before they didn't it's not
all it's just japanese businesses
in general like to know if they're a
real person or just you know
like just the idea of judge if there are
good people so like that
if joey wasn't in japan right yeah would
there possibly have been
no collaboration because like if joey
our first conversation was actually on
skype right right would that would have
been good enough to secure a deal do you
reckon
probably not probably not unless there's
like a foreigner in the group like
at that time i was like the only
foreigner working probably yeah yeah
i was the first foreigner yeah because i
remember like when i went to the bulk
walker office as well that was like
probably the first time i ever went to
like a like a physical
meeting in japan and since then god i've
every time a japanese company's like
we'd like to meet up with you to discuss
this thing i'm like
do you know what email is i don't want
to leave i think without like
i mean you guys starting it i feel like
they wouldn't have even considered
youtubers right
i almost feel like the japanese
companies too it took me like four
months to get approved no not four
months maybe two months
to get approved which is actually
incredibly fast compared to some of the
other projects
my number changing my email changes i
had to like do
i guess bs a lot of bs a lot of like
data oh my god i'm gonna get caught
i'll be like did you cook the books
i crunched the numbers i made graphs i
was like the inflow from
youtube is like the best for i don't
know reaching the hearts
of teenagers
yeah so i i still probably have that
slide and i was like
how well youtubers can reach their
viewers hearts you're probably wondering
for the past hour
what are these figures we don't know
what this is well it's because this
episode is sponsored by
ej anime stores usually standing for
entertainment with japan by the way
ej anime store is calacao's official
anime store that sells
anime gaming manga directly from japan
if you didn't know counter cow has
published huge titles such as
evangelion it's it's capitalized in the
script the harahi suzumiya series
re-zero conosuba and more and because
catechol is producing these directly
what better way to support the industry
itself
there is no better way look at all these
beautiful things that we have on the
table that are from ej anime store that
you can get your hands on
right now look at all this arsenal
there's three asanas in front well
actually four
asanas in front of me right now what
does what does ej stand for again
entertainment japan to give you an idea
of the stuff that you can get at ej
anime store they've brought in a few of
the items oh
jesus christ speak of the devil this is
one of the things that you can get at ej
anime store what is it god did you have
to aim for my face melon
this is from fates do you do you know
fate connor
it's from one of the spin-offs it's from
fate khalid
ilya prisma so we don't have it here but
it should be on screen
which is the fate caladia linear prisma
my god elia
ilias valve von eisenburn wedding bikini
version
one slash scale figure i'm [ __ ] dying
i just pronounced but it does come with
the t-shirt that god is modeling if you
do buy that figure
look at that beautiful this is the only
fate franchise you should care about
because there's lesbian lollies in it i
don't know if i'm allowed to say that
but
it's in the shop i'm also told the
clothing veil and other clear parts are
painted with pearl coloring the veil
perio and bouquet are detachable there's
also this figure which is the data
bullets light novel white queen
seventh scale figure catacower special
sets and this figurine already looks
just
absolutely incredible this is [ __ ]
great so much detail and the best part
about it is if you get
this beautiful figurine then you can
also get this lovely b2 tapestry set
with it as well
for free for free gentlemen
there's also my favorite anime series
sorted out online this is a sword
online figure eyes standard asana dengue
color limited version set with
a beautiful asana tapestry as well that
comes with it as a special bonus there's
also
these two other asanas as well which has
the asana vacation
set i mean she looks like she's having a
good time on the beach there oh yeah
that's uh she's about to get lathered up
there's the regular version and then
there's
the alo version if you want your own
beach episode there you go
yeah it comes with the beach if you like
any of these figures be sure to go check
them out at ejanimestore.com or click
the link in the description below as
they've only recently opened there will
be tons of more merchandise coming out
soon so stay tuned conan what is this
entertainment man
thank you for sponsoring guys by the way
back to the videos so did youtubers work
mailing
don't we going to scratch my i don't
know did they why are you guys here
i guess so yeah i think i think like one
thing that
a lot of people might be interested in
is that you're a foreigner working
in like the anime and manga industry in
japan you're basically leaving the weeb
dream yeah
yeah so like how did how did that happen
how did you find a job
in book walker katakawa as a foreigner
you know
i i know this i think i know the answer
to this craigslist tokyo
tokyo cake do you want to tell the story
about how that happened
oh well i was working at a marketing
consulting company in japan
right because you you've been living
here because you had married to a
japanese
person well yeah like my first second
year in japan but
um yeah i was working at a marketing
digital marketing
agency being a consultant for several
different japanese companies who wanted
to like
get i don't know foreign not foreign
global traffic to their site or
something yeah they said that was that
would count as foreign yeah
yeah i don't know what you're freaking
calm down
am i sweating
oh yeah [ __ ] you threw me off and now
i'm like wait what was i even talking
you were talking about how you got the
job at bulk oh yeah and then okay and
then
i needed a bicycle one day and i
finished my work
and it was like during lunch time and i
was like oh i can just check craigslist
for you know cheap bicycle
like 30 bucks 20 bucks i'm checking on
craigslist and then i found the bicycle
i didn't buy it though and then i was
like oh i wonder if there's like
actually
legit jobs on craigslist besides like
foot massage whatever it is looking for
f
yeah cause you know that's the image
that craigslist has in america
yeah yeah yeah or or a fridge full of
coffee yeah you're the one
yeah you made me get that [ __ ] fridge
cockroach
when you buy something on craigslist you
first look at it in person and then you
decide i'm not going to some
[ __ ] person's house to check out a
ten dollar fridge maybe why didn't you
amazon it
then because well now he knows better no
well now
he knows i really insisted that this the
cockroaches
the craigslist may as well be a call
correct because this changed my life you
were
so insistent so insisted that craigslist
dude you should really go to craigslist
man you're gonna get a mad deal i was
like
fine meline fine i'll get i'll get a
fridge from craigslist
and then it got had [ __ ] cockroaches
in it but now you have a story
i do have a story yeah we had a story
but yeah i hate you so so this job what
did it say what what jobs did you find
on there oh i think it's like looking
for f
in it said like digital
manga marketing specialist and i was
like what
they're looking for something like that
i click it and it doesn't say the name
of the company
it says like oh chiyoda idabashi and i'm
like wait there's only two publishers
that i know of
in this area and i was like it's either
this really big one or like this
kind of the biggest one and i google all
the
well i knew it was katakala so i was
like oh i'm going to google every single
katakawa
like department and see what they're
like what they're looking
for looking for and then i found before
and it matched exactly
kind of what the craigslist thing was
which was
oh looking for someone to go overseas to
different anime conventions
to
no japanese required and this was like
four
five five years ago and like my japanese
is nowhere fluent
and at that time it was even more
horrible so
into the anime industry or manga
industry you need to like speak
english or not english i'm japanese
japanese yeah and japanese like fluently
yeah
beyond business and uh so i was like oh
i'm never going to work in the manga
street unless it's like in america
than i could yeah why'd you got it
that's that's like insane because if i
saw that adam ad on craigslist
again i would like think it was a scam
or something yeah like imagine
a cow going on like advertising a
[ __ ] job on craigslist
they didn't say the company name though
but it's still on craigslist
that makes it even more sketchy right i
really expect it to just be like coda
cola like
it's like one it's like oh it almost
sounds like
i was gonna do a video on craigslist i
remember
why are you laughing i suck dick for
videos
like i wanted to see what was on there
and so i found this ad that was like uh
looking for youtubers
uh below ten thousand and i was like
what what
what they're all about yeah this is in
london so i called them up
and it was what no no not japan i don't
know okay i don't feel weird about that
in japan
and so i caught them up and they were
like yeah we want to pay youtubers
uh below ten thousand dollars uh uh
below ten thousand subscribers
five thousand dollars to move to our
platform exclusively i caught this woman
on the phone
i didn't tell her i had like a million
subs and she was just like she was going
on and she was like
yeah so uh we just need you to be in an
exclusive deal with our partners
and and all this and i was so confused i
was like what the [ __ ] i've never heard
of this platform
yeah and then they were like oh yeah but
uh because i was a guy obviously
yeah but we're only interested in women
as well and i was like
that's like red flags coming up yeah
yeah i'm just like
i don't know i wonder if i'd like
stumbled onto like the greatest like
prostitution network or something i
don't know what it was to this
yeah i still don't know i have the phone
call recorded on my pc
um yeah and then i told them at a
million subs and then they uh they were
like oh no we're not interested
why two thousand well i was really
confused about that
is it because like if like you know they
they want to like drop out for example
if there's like drama they're like oh
this guy's only got ten thousand
subscribers they won't go anywhere they
kept saying stuff that was like too good
to be true they were like
we'll give you five thousand dollars to
move we were in the uk as well by the
way
that was already like that's weird and
then also they were like we can give you
premium
ad rev rates of like 10 cpm i'm like
get out of here all the cp [ __ ] off
no way i was losing it i i wish to this
day i still want to know what that was i
don't know why i told that you even
checked
thoroughly they wouldn't tell me what it
was they were like it's on it's download
it's on the download and i'm like that's
weird
this sounds that sounds sketch as [ __ ]
that sounds scary that sounds like uh
it sounds like a hiring ring for like a
prostitution like a black market
prostitution
that's why that's why i never want to
use craigslist because every single
story i've heard from craigslist is
apart from yours apart from that apart
from mainland outside of japan i think
there's a sketch right like yeah have
you gone to like the
the like you know the section where you
can you know
pay for favors you can oh yeah yeah oh
no that's like the community or
something like that
there's one where it's like for old
people and it's all just like 40
50 year old woman looking for like dudes
to just give them a good is this this
isn't
in japan uh yeah yeah and the uk
and the us i checked all of them because
i wanted to see if there's anything
crazy about craigslist
don't tell me you're going to make a
video no i didn't okay thank god
so tell me that's where all the hot sexy
singles
are increasing in my area they're all
incredible it's not kiss anime god damn
it
that's why you're not homesick what if
you just like what if you just like
clicked on the kiss anime ads and it
just takes you to the crisis
it makes sense it's wild because there
was like 40 year old women who were
married
showing their face and giving their
mobile phone number and i was like whoa
you are playing with that
she says that doesn't sound safe but
also you're married right yeah
i saw your face karen
every karen is like you don't know if
it's their real photo
yeah yeah it might it could be very much
a scam definitely have to be their
number though right i mean
i don't know unless i guess i guess you
have to find out
i would totally call her just for a
video i do that i mean i have like no
qualms about doing that like yeah
i'm bad okay but like steering back to
the conversation sorry yes
yeah yeah back to the conversation so
like i i think we can all agree that
like maylene's story is
very much a rare case right like is that
a rare case i
i think so i've never heard of anyone
getting into the anime industry through
craigslist
i think there's people who you probably
most people know or you guys know are in
the us
working for us yeah what's there ever
time you were gonna
you wanted to work in the u.s industry
that is the most nervous smile i've ever
seen yeah i did there was there was
probably two companies that i applied to
that were
yet rejected mainly rejected you're
rejected is that why you
but they called back and they're like
you are the second candidate
that hurts even more i don't hear that
yeah when i was a fresh graduate
right do you want to know if you haven't
got the job i don't want to know i just
want to apply i want to know no i want
to make sure i also
like i don't know want to know the
reason they're not going to give them
they're never going to give it to you
i guarantee every person who dropped
they said you were the second one
i guarantee you honestly we wanted to we
wanted to really that's what i would do
but like what would be because i'm
[ __ ] certain right that not just
people watching this episode but i
reckon like
every weeb living overseas yeah
probably has that dream somewhere in the
back of their head where they're like
man
i want to move to japan i want to work
in the enemies you get those emails as
well
yeah everyone gets them right we all get
them right so as someone who actually
made it yeah what is the advice you
would give
to people who like want to chase that
dream did the speedrun round
yeah it took a year and a half i think
that's pretty fascinating
yeah yeah no no you didn't get the green
card to move here
i was like what no i mean that's the
easiest way though right i mean there's
pretty guys
like i can marry someone again no no not
really
i mean are true true but like what
advice would you give for someone who's
like looking to work in the industry
in japan yeah yeah the most realistic
yeah like
if you don't yeah i would say learn some
a lot of like learn japanese that's like
the easiest way to get in
like there's that jlpt where it's n1n2
or whatever
and i've heard like oh n2 is like if you
can get to n2 you can pretty much snag
like any job that's not like too late
you're
you're not extremely knowledgeable about
like the industry
right that's like the biggest thing
because people ask us all the time
they're like you know what's the best
way and i'm like bro i'm like
in the weirdest situation yeah this is
just me don't don't take my career path
yeah
that's a really weird career we just
want to stress we're not part of the
industry
we work with the industry we are not
part of the industry why are you asking
a youtuber on immigration law
i don't know anything you think i know
immigration
[ __ ] dude you should because you
immigrated here i barely know how to
file my taxes
come on but like a lot of japanese in uh
like companies hiring foreigners
yes yes they do actually quite a lot are
especially in the past
year or two right they've expanded to
like the global market
people because people watching this
write that down
japan knows how popular anime is
overseas that's why of course there's
like the cool japan thing
if book walker did a uh uh job
application today what would my cv my
resume need to look like
like what are we looking for because
because and you can you can tell us this
because you're probably going to be like
if the job opening ever opens up
you you'd probably be the one doing the
interview right so what would
what what do you expect from someone's
got to be on that tv
i don't know i'm not in like that team
anymore give us your thoughts mainly
like like hypothetically because because
you
you always have to hide from geeks plus
which is also very similar
in cell or something
[Laughter]
like don't
yeah and have like a social life kind of
because like you got those really weird
can you can you really when they when
they come in do you can like can you
you sense it straight away we did some
like interviews recently actually where
we were like
we did it through zoom or like right
around yeah and like the thing i was
like
looking for is like they smile and
like i don't smile and then i also like
we asked them what's your favorite anime
series or something
and it's not the anime series they
choose it's the reason why they like it
or whatever
if they say naruto normie get out of
here
i was like oh my god he said that's
serious no no
every application you're going to have
from now on for like every cv it's just
not an in-cell yeah
smiles in a zoom coil
i'd say experience is like the biggest
thing because experience in what
working in like just anything actually
yeah
because i i i feel like that's a lot of
a lot of experience that a lot of people
are missing you know that just working
in a company environment is is actually
really valuable
experiences yeah corporate experience
definitely or if they're like fresh
graduate to at least have a few like
internships under your belt
because there's some people like in my
like previous companies i've worked with
in the past like they're new graduates
they go into the job and they don't even
know how to use excel
so if they're like familiar with all the
microsoft
stuff i mean it's it's something you
never like actively learn how to use
like excellent word but it's like such a
necessary
like skill to have working in a
corporate job yeah which is
which is knowing how to use excel it's
not on any like job application
job application but it's fun when i was
working on the bbc
i had to use excel for [ __ ]
everything i'm convinced my engineering
degree was an excel degree in disguise
because i used excel for everything yeah
yeah everything we had like
we had classes in high school that was
specifically towards excel
oh yeah yeah so what's like the main
points right on a resume
like what if there's a three most things
that you can have as a candidate
for for applying what what what stands
out the most
we're not talking about like don't be an
insult like apparently actually like
i'm not like the final judge for this no
no but just like your opinion yeah
in your opinion in your opinion just
like like the way they write
their like intro paragraph about
themselves
oh sure that's actually important well i
don't know for me
i read it i'm just like what do they say
like do they sound passionate or they're
just copying and pasting
top 10 best ways to write a cover letter
or something oh yeah in japan don't you
have to write
every uh like letter and like resume by
hand
yeah that's disgusting oh yeah yeah oh
my god that's that's
that's too much so there's like what is
that what is the little job fair they do
when they're like leave school what's
that called
yeah and they they can write up to 100
applications
by hand the same [ __ ] yeah i would lose
my damn
i had to do that when i was applying for
internships in japan
i think i rode 30. jesus and that wasn't
nearly as
as much as some of what like my friends
did apparently they look out for like if
you care enough
and i'm like to me that just like seems
like why is this the thing that we're
caring about yeah
i don't care i just want money yeah give
me the experience i'm gonna make you
money
yeah shut up give me this can we just be
honest here and just say why do you need
this job because
i'm broke yeah and i just graduated and
i need the [ __ ] money okay i need a
job
just give me the job i do like it when
they're extremely passionate too
like not saying like oh my god i'm like
a huge love liver and i love life
for everything it's more like you know i
was in a different shout out to the love
life
i
you know why because their loyalty will
never lie with you ever yeah no matter
what
but you can bribe them that's true but
for how long can you break the news how
long how long can you bribe them you
haven't finished this
gripping it because okay all right your
phone just slammed on the floor very
dramatic
but okay right let's say you know
they're they're addicted to gacha who
knows
how long it is before they they do one
too many gat rolls they come at you with
a raise they want to raise maybe yeah
they've been broke they wouldn't ask me
they would ask like the ceo for the
raids
right okay then what then how would you
respond to that
uh well first i would ask oh what have
you been doing this past year
differently
and like how much have you affected this
like
how much has the sales been affected by
your work and what do you want to try
doing
differently if i gave you this much
money what are you going to do like
how's it going it's basically really
going to better your life so it's
basically another job interview
is what i'm what i'm hearing is what
i've heard i mean i don't have any
underlying
because one thing i find fascinating is
how the story of like we
we all have you to thank for like this
podcast and being here in japan and
because it's all a lot this yeah
it's an awful lot of what we've done is
thanks to maelyn she's like the
brainchild to a lot of it
but like i finally just got lucky okay
yeah but like how did the story of geeks
plus forming
come to be because you may geek oh
geeksplus is the agency that we're all
oh yeah yeah and the reason why we're
here
and the reason why we're here so like
how did how did that come about
so like kalaukawa has like a new
business
contest or competition every year and
then within their like departments they
also do like
business competitions right and
the first year i decided to like submit
something in it was
the king spot thing oh yeah
usually well i didn't want to submit it
before because there was like where the
prize money was like this much
and then this particular year the prize
money was like this and i was like
maybe i want that money i'm gonna beat
it
so wait i gotta ask okay because i
remember the exact meeting where you
asked me
have have you she asked me in a meeting
have you ever considered moving to japan
yeah we're just
casually talking we're just casually
talking but did you have that prize
money and that
competition in mind when you asked me
hey man i respect it i
are you allowed to tell us how much you
got i think okay so like
people will say oh it's not that much
but it was like i think they told me
it's like oh the prize is gonna be like
really that's like that's like a decent
bonus
that's not bad but what i want to know
is how you manage to convince them
because we as we've all talked about
japanese companies are [ __ ] difficult
they never want to train anything to try
anything new and convincing japanese
companies to send over like three or
four
annie tubers and just sponsor their
visas and
well uh you guys have been working with
like bookwalker for at that point like
two three years already
yeah so i had data and like
yeah but as we know that we know how we
audio
that's not always the case right like
that's not guaranteed that wasn't enough
though this is like three years worth
never enough it's all about that data
yeah god damn it
the excel sheets exactly
excel sheets and powerpoints and so i
think in the back of their mind
they were already thinking like oh if we
had this business it would be
interesting
and my superior boss at that time was
like give me a tip oh maybe you should
submit
that idea because maybe they're thinking
about it yeah and i
was like okay i guess i have enough data
so let's do it
and then i won the thingy and
did you have like was it like an
apprentice type pitch where you had to
like
go into like a boardroom meeting and
yeah i attended one yeah
oh really yeah i i was uh the like first
week i moved here they were like do you
want to come to this thing
yeah then you met mr cuddle call it like
yeah i meant like yeah yeah it was weird
because i just sat down in like the most
like like sterile room you could imagine
imagine like just like 100 200 japanese
businessmen in the quietest room in your
life and i came in
because i came in midway so i was making
so much [ __ ] noise just trying to sit
down
of course my my seat was in the middle
yeah you were like the only
non-asians
i was the only one not on the suit of
some sort as well
so i come in with like my t-shirt and
jeans
i'm like sorry excuse me excuse me i sat
down
and then uh one of the japanese people
kept translating in my ear and i was
like just stop translating
i'm making too much noise and people are
looking at us yeah i'll just i'll just
pretend like i know what
yeah but they were all really good
sports about it they were nice to me it
was like that
we had like a new business plan format
document you fill it out
and then within that i think it was like
over 200 maybe around 200 applicants
and then it narrowed down to like 50 and
then when you're the top
50 they narrow it you don't do anything
you just like
make like a three year uh business plan
yeah
when why did i go again there was free
food and drink
that was really good sushi and free beer
yeah that was like pretty good
drink i'll go to anything yeah yeah
exactly okay not gonna lie right you
were bored probably
i was really i had no internet they
didn't arrive
i think i felt bad because i've been
crashing on joey's couch for like a week
i felt really bad that was bothering him
so much
that's fine but yeah and then
okay right this is the thing right
company parties at least in japan they
don't span any expense with food and
drink like they like they do such good
food
okay marlene's a food snob i don't count
her opinion yeah yeah
it was good okay okay but like they have
like bomb
food and drink yeah yeah yeah it's like
that's always so good so good
like like they'll have like restaurant
quality like food just there for you
you're like yeah okay yeah it is a
restaurant though
well no it's like a hotel and they just
bring in a platter and you just like dig
in
yeah it's like sweet and all you can
drink and alcohol
yeah yeah yeah that's good people
awkward people
in the the japanese women taking photos
oh yeah
they were like they're like this is the
guy who made the yowie the one that you
have to check for the sex noises
the book walker like support team i
think they're mostly women
and then like that's so weird
this is the man they are like all
fangirls of you i think
they're 93 let's go
let's go confused because like none of
them could speak english so i was like
why
why are you listening to myself for the
reason why they knew about you
was because i think last year when we
did the first audio book
uh they were playing it on speaker
because
they would get like emails from
customers saying oh i don't know how to
play this mp3
and so they're like oh let's check if
there's a problem and they play it and
they just end up playing it on speakers
they play the new one on speaker one has
like a hardcore sex scene like yeah i
don't
know because uh what is it corona virus
that was weird because then i was just
eating and then they were like can we
take a picture and i'm like who are you
why are you where are your fan girls
what is this
it's so weird so did you expect to win
the competition at all or was it like a
[ __ ] surprise for you yeah
uh kind of a surprise i guess
i knew i was the best no no like
well my my boss at the time was saying
like oh you have like
maybe like a high probability because
yeah he
was the one reviewing the other business
thing oh okay so maybe he helped me a
lot
i mean it's a pretty radical idea right
especially in like such a traditional
company power right so do you know what
other ideas you were competing against
yeah it was they're
kind of like manga service like manga
subscription or something like that
i would be good as well i mean that
would be good for japan
so like i kind of want to talk about the
opening party of geeks plus because
that was probably the most extra
business party i've ever been to oh my
god
so sad yes so connor wasn't there
connor wasn't there because he was he
was he was at the crunchyroll anime
awards yeah so he was
there was about like 10 ipads scattered
around this entire life
three three ipads okay three ipads
whatever scattered around this like
two-star michelin restaurant what was
the restaurant that he was like
yeah so i didn't know that kadukawa
owned so many
things outside of just like anime and
manga yeah
yeah and so we were at this two-star
michelin restaurant and
connor had to join us via skype or zoom
or whatever you were using it's like
a stupid time for you right like [ __ ]
like face was like this
it was like yeah like 10 11 p.m or
something yeah yeah
yeah and then and then i had to do a
speech and it was like the most [ __ ]
awful sweet
i remember like you were like in the
[ __ ] hotel room like
like a downward like because i was like
it's like
yeah he said it all in japanese and i
was like
wow no nobody nope
[Music]
no ice cream so this is like there are a
lot of
important people at this party like how
many people are there maybe like 50 plus
right yeah 50 plus
basically it was like there was like mr
caterpillar was there
um there was like pretty much any anime
company my anime was ceo
the ceo of my anime list was there i
didn't i didn't even know that he was
japanese you know
danny chu was there yeah yeah yeah yeah
basically like
any company that is like in japan any
big company there was a representative
for
that company there this is like the
biggest dick energy i've ever been yeah
and connor on a night so i remember we
had to
we had to do a speech in front of all
these important people
and i remember um the uh ceo of
geeksplus
um like kind of he introduced us
to like make our speech and i was i was
like [ __ ] [ __ ] myself
because man i could see you as [ __ ] i
was [ __ ] myself because i had to
talk in front of all these [ __ ]
people
and i couldn't speak a lick of japanese
so i had to just like
i had to speak in english but i remember
that he introduced us and i remember
hearing something like
oh the heroes of anime
and i turned to joey i turned to joey
and i i i
and i was like um my japanese isn't like
the greatest but did he just call us the
heroes of anime for western anime fans
and joey was just like
yeah yeah and i was just thinking about
thinking to myself
why would he lie like that the heroes
like i was just like doing the blinking
meals like
i'm sorry fair though like i would say
it's kind of true
like there's a lot of people that i know
there's a lot
there's a lot of people who would
disagree with that and i'm not sure why
a lot of people call us the villains of
anime anything right
some people probably who are like in the
middle of nowhere that have no anime
friends and they're getting bullied for
it and they're like oh these people are
like anime and they're actually cool
they punch them back like anime is not a
lame thing
yeah you're cool i know all i remember
was like i was i was suited up sydney
was suited up and then
like joey rocks up in [ __ ] uh i can't
remember what you were wearing
and i was like and i looked at like i
looked at gaunt like so properly dressed
as like collar
shirt and everything sydney was in like
this really nice dress and i'm just
there with like my
jeans and like [ __ ] sneakers and i'm
just like sup hero of anime here
but they're like i did that to another
player though this is like oh my god
that's how
youtubers dress that's right you know
[ __ ] celebrity
i don't think that anyone understood
what i actually said in my speech you're
the only one who
anyone could understand yeah i mean i
mean a lot of them did
yeah because you started speaking and
the speakers just weren't on
so all we could see was
it was an amazing speech it was such a
good speech what was more hilarious was
just not only just not
conor's speakers not being on but just
50 japanese businessmen just like really
seriously just looking down at the ipad
just being like
you're paying you have to bear attention
mind as well
i can't see anything like i'm just
talking into a webcam like
i don't see [ __ ] so as far as i know
like i'm just talking in the [ __ ]
void over here for my shitty japanese
boku no name
my god that was really funny yeah but no
that was like a
really interesting experience for me
because that was like a
holy [ __ ] moment have i made it is this
the point we met some really [ __ ]
cool people there yeah
who was like yeah which i did
it was like stood out the most or which
company did you like freak out over it
i was so i mean it was there yeah i mean
obviously like you know the shawn and
jump
guys were there yeah but i think the the
coolest one because just because it just
kind of came out of nowhere was i think
i was talking to the sean and jump
people
and they were like what like what what
mugger do you like
like what are you interested in
obviously i laid out a bunch of show
name jump stuff and then one of the guys
was like oh well like what about stuff
that's not shown a jump like i'm just
genuinely curious right and i think i
said berserk
because i [ __ ] love berserk and then
literally the moment after i said
berserk some guy tapped me on the
shoulder and was like hi i'm the
publisher for berserk
i was like the editor was
like things like dusty he's like i've
never done that i've been hired for five
years and i haven't done anything i've
never even met mira in my life
no and and so i he he said that and i
read the card i'm like oh [ __ ] yeah that
is like the publication of berserk yeah
and i just said like um not to be rude
what the [ __ ] is mira doing what is he
doing what's going on what's going on
what's going on with that
what's up let's jump right into it like
you publish like you're his publisher
right like yeah
what just give me the details what's
going on yeah what's he doing and he's
like oh no he's working hard don't worry
i'm like
yeah that's what they all say idol
master in the background
i'm working hard i'm working hard i'm
working hard you're winning son
yeah no but that was really cool danny
chu was really cool danny was he was one
because like i think it's safe to say
that
danny chu is one of those people who
really put anime just like weeb culture
in the west just like on the map because
i i think i think it's not too much of a
stretch to say that without danny chu's
influence
i don't think any of us would really
even be interested in japanese culture
no no
he did so much for not only like our
culture but our industry as well because
he was one of the first like foreigners
who moved to japan and really put a
highlight on a lot of things going on in
the japanese industry
yeah exactly because before i remember
it was just like japan was just kind of
a black hole
nobody knew [ __ ] that was like what that
was happening in japan we just got anime
somehow
but he actually like spotlighted a lot
of the things going on
and if not for him i probably wouldn't
even have even considered moving to
japan or
you know have any interest in the
industry itself great like motivational
speeches at a lot of events like anime
expo
yeah and he's a really down-to-earth guy
so humble yeah
incredibly incredible considering
everything he's done he's like so humble
and so downtown
she showed up with his doll yeah yeah he
showed up with his smartphone oh yeah
that was so cool
yeah but you should have been there bro
i'm i'm pissed off how was the
crunchyroll anime awards compared to
that
do you really want to go into that no i
mean
one day i came back in my room and there
was a trash bag full of stuff that
wasn't mine
can you believe that i went in a hotel
in my hotel room who went in there
i don't know i caught them up and i'm
like hey there's uh just a
giant bag of trash in my room uh what's
up with that they're like really
they're like they didn't believe me i'm
like yeah i'm like come come
the maids probably clean well yeah what
i think they did is the maids were
cleaning and they just forgot it back so
i didn't care
yeah yeah they gave me a letter that was
like dear sea dog sorry that we left
trash in your room
i was like why is it sea dog probably
the name they put on the like
no it was connor because i checked in
with my real name and i know
the guy must have known or something it
was weird as [ __ ] because then he gave
me another bottle of wine
but it was like a terrible hotel screw
cap
i'm like this is i won't even cook with
this [ __ ] like
no offense like it's just garbage wine i
mean i'm not picky but even i knew that
but how was the how was the actual
awards
yeah how was it for you because we both
we both went on different years
how was it i mean the i imagine it's the
same for you the best aspect was just
chatting to the other creators yeah like
it felt like a holiday where you just
got to like meet other creators chipotle
i've been missing chipotle
although i kept i i was like because we
would all eat lunch together right and i
was like
chipotle i want chipotle and then uh one
of the i forgot her name from ign
uh i think she was hispanic and she was
like no chipotle is garbage
all right i'm like listen i come from a
place well
recently where they don't have any
chipotle or met you know how hard it is
to find a burrito
bigger than like your index finger in
this country impossible
i think out of every cuisine mexican is
one of the hardest to find in japan yeah
i want a burrito that like [ __ ] kills
me so anyway that's the yeah i had
it was nice having lunch with them sorry
i'm going on the run yeah but yeah it
was really cool their offices were cool
they'd made it into like yeah you got to
see their offices they didn't then
though
yeah it was cool i mean i felt like a
little extra like i don't know i yeah
there was a lot of free lacroix i didn't
really care for lacroix
millennials the most disgusting thing
is is that like white claw no no no no
no lacroix is like
it's like salty water flavored sparkling
water yeah
it was weird i think you went two years
in a row yeah and i didn't go to the one
where they were streaming at the twitch
headquarters were they streaming on the
twitch club
they were streaming their office oh okay
so there was like
a back room with a small crowd of about
a hundred people
yeah and it was fine i i really got
bored of how many times had to practice
how many times did you have to rehearse
because we only had to rehearse once
jesus what were they rehearsing i i
think it was for the host
uh he had a lot of lines i for me it was
easy i just
during the rehearsals by the way i mean
gone okay so i got to tell the story
right
so they they were like they they wanted
us to have a mixture of scripted and do
your own stuff so yeah
as i think it should be right like i
want to be on track but i also want to
you know be myself
so they would ask me a question that was
connor who do you think is best girl
and um during this story
during during rehearsals right i never
said like anything even remotely me me i
was like oh yeah like rem
yeah yeah and then i texted gone like an
hour before the show started i was like
yo give me the worst girl
give me the worst best girl and i will
dead ass say this
like straight face in front of all these
people like i'll do it yeah i'll do it
on the twitch stream i don't know
because i thought i want to make this
funny yeah in a good way that wasn't
[ __ ] with crunchyroll
that we could get a bit of laughter out
and i said nina from code gear that was
that was the first name that came to
mind so
i remember i said that joke and [ __ ]
craps like
no one thought i watched the stream
yeah i was pissing myself i was [ __ ]
pissing myself thought to myself because
i knew no one was gonna laugh at this
joke right and i just taught myself i
was like the twitch
twitch chat they're gonna love it yeah
chat's gonna love this i don't mind
i'll just put up with the awkward
silence for like one second i i was
watching the twitch stream and the
moment you said that i
died which chat was [ __ ] loving it
yeah yeah but like the crowd and the
audience and everyone's there
i remember i remember the moment i said
it right for some reason
jacob from faku was in the crowd and i i
just made eye contact with jacob and he
looked like this
i was like i was like and then i think i
made like a
joke or something i made something to
like try and segue it and it didn't work
very well obviously but i didn't give a
[ __ ]
it made for a great clip because it was
like so perfectly timed with my stream
because i was like
yeah i told conor to say nina and as
soon as i said that you said you said it
and it was just like the most perfectly
timed moment i could ever hope for
yeah she asked me okay well the reason
why
it's connected in in the chat he was
like they're gonna ask me
it's because i just see my best girl
all-time best girls
connor nina from cody
yeah it was it was good i mean it was uh
it was fun i mean i
got to we hung out in like the green
room or whatever
it was chill just chatting with uh i
remember
i chat with prose d a lot really cool
guy yeah um
that man knows his anime he knows a lot
of animals he knows so much
because i had a similar conversation
with him and i'm like
man you know more anime than most
antitubers
[Applause]
he was just in this room and it was
silent then you would just hear someone
playing the [ __ ] love life
just prozy sitting there like this he's
a love liver
yeah yeah yeah oh he's a hard yeah yeah
it's so i love it when
like when he would talk because it would
be like whenever prose d talked everyone
in the room was like yes pro cd
well i'll listen to you he's such a
commanding voice yeah amazing
who has the deeper voice in real life
it's like just two mumbles talking about
things
talking because he's like i'll give
mcdonald's yeah i'll get mcdonald's
i'm just the sub with this
i remember the most were like not the
actual like awards yeah i remember the
same i don't remember anything
happened was that when i was on stage
because i remember um when i was on
was when i was on the giant crowd on
this it was a big [ __ ]
crowd like how big was your crowd like
no more than 100
right because we were like they rented
out a whole stage in la or something
they had like a
red carpet which is like an orange
carpet it was like
it was charming about like it was
because it was still like a small scale
event but they really tried to
dress this up to look like something
official and you know there was a lot of
technical difficulties and mess and mess
up but
that's probably like you know you know
they were if you watched the stream the
technical difficulties in that year were
glorious but they
were they they made for like great meme
material it was like it was like
charming in its own way because
it wasn't like the game awards it wasn't
the [ __ ] oscars but you know they
tried their best
and i think for what they had they did
like a pretty decent job yeah b
plus for effort yeah i think it's i
think they said that they wanted to dial
it back this year to make it a
little more like have personalities
shine through a bit more but
it's it's still hard because i think you
know the sometimes you know some people
aren't as good
on stage as others yeah right is that
your first time like kind of
hosting i wasn't really doing anything
he was literally just sitting on a couch
yeah cracking jokes i don't really get
to the only thing i was nervous about
was cracking that joke like everything
because i knew that was gonna i knew
i knew no one would laugh but i didn't
mind but other than that i really don't
mind doing stuff like that that's fun
like i remember the only the only weird
thing that happened when i was on stage
um was i was with uh i was standing next
to lily because i was
hosting with lily peachy when i was
presenting my awards and so i was
staying at the bright
bright lights and all i heard was
and i thought someone said i love you
guys and i and i shout out in the crunch
of all awards i love you too man
and then i watch the vods and the guy
shouts out
i love you lilly yeah
that's even better i would be like no i
love you i love you
you may not love me but yeah i love you
i mean i don't think anyone noticed it
but yeah i thought i thought you were
just screaming for us both yeah that guy
when they did the final award at our
control anime awards they had like a
giant like what is it called the [ __ ]
thing they opened what's it
okay no i think it is they all had sake
that's part of the story but they had
like the big boxes that we had the
like the the names of the winners in oh
yeah the anime of the year had like a
giant one
oh yeah yeah i don't know i don't know
what they're called i know what they're
talking about
the giant one they were like yeah okay
everyone's gonna go on stage and we
have a fake sake for you it's water and
i was like oh cool cool cool
so i have it right and i'm i'm smelling
it like next to lily i think you can see
me and lily
in the vaults like visual confusion
because we do it and we're like that's
that's [ __ ] sacking
they told us it was [ __ ] water and
then like me and lily are like god
that's [ __ ] vile
yeah that's gross they lied to us
cut you all what if i was allergic to
alcohol
they gave you free alcohol and you
didn't even know
yeah because there was there was alcohol
right after the after part surprise
alcohol okay so we know that you're now
working for bulk walker and geeks plus
and all that that's really great million
so i said so condescending because
because that's not what i care about
i want to know what you were doing when
you were younger in japan what jobs are
you doing
we want to we want to know about your
weaknesses
what is your path to getting to where
you are now we want the viewers
to recognize with your shonen
protagonist
we need to build up we we've told all
we've told all of our back stories yeah
it's time to first tell your backstory
okay so i used to go to a lot of anime
conventions
as you do yes yeah and uh where am i
going for this
so you met your husband right yeah yeah
uh that's the thing
i forgot to tell the story or not sorry
i wanted to say like the biggest tip is
to envision
what position you want in the animus
industry and make
like steps to get there right the steps
i made for myself is one keep going to a
lot of anime conventions and make
friends
yeah that work in like some
like in the industry yeah and
one of the people that i met at a
convention
happened to bring like japanese uh
rock bands right like yeah yeah japanese
rock bands to the u.s
anime conventions and then that person
like introduced me to a lot of people
that
were in japan and the hardest thing for
a foreigner
or not foreigner for someone to get
their sorry
the hardest thing is to get into japan
with the visa
finding a job that will give you a visa
when you don't speak good japanese is
extremely difficult
so the first thing i did was get
a job that has no relation to anime to
get the
experience and then try to do
a consulting job that consults for anime
figure like type of companies oh okay
and then after that meet people
from that industry get the know-how from
them yeah
and then apply to the job that i have
now
but uh gosh i'm like it's calculated
but it's yeah but at the end of the day
you know it's that age-old like it's not
what you know it's who you know yeah
it is like i i think i've heard like
similar stories with uh other friends
like nabi
who i like i had no idea how he knew so
many people in the industry i remember
asking him and
he was just like yeah just go to enough
events just talk to enough people
there's a lot of events here yeah for me
i'm like a nervous wreck
like yeah we can tell
do not be fooled by meleen's nervousness
she is a killer all right
you guys in the room so that's why i'm
like comfortable was like there's more
than that
yeah holy oh my god this would be soaked
yeah so like you have to meet people
network yeah and like
a lot of people find that difficult in
the us and everything and like and
abroad because the only place i could
possibly think of is like conventions
and everything but in japan there are
like so many official events
that you can go to to meet people what
would you recommend then
like what should people look out for if
they wanted to just you know be in the
right place at the right time
um there's a lot of facebook groups
actually and
a lot of these facebook groups are for
like the otaku community and sometimes
they have industry people
as surprise guests or like just show up
yeah so go to those and you can meet
people or when there's like
they're kind of like panels industry
panels you can meet people
at the after party of these things okay
yeah i've i've like from experience
i've had people one thing i know that
doesn't work
is to just go up to someone is to just
go up to someone and be like hey
i'm this person here's my business card
call me oh yeah and i'm just like
i don't know what you do what do you
want to do with me
oh like i've had that so much they come
to you really like suave like
yeah here's my card yeah i expect to
hear from you you small talk first
though
yeah yeah well well like you know at
least explain like what is the purpose
of you coming up right
now yeah going up to people right like
what do you what what is the kind of
connection that you want it's not just
about like
i want to make a connection because i
want a connection yeah it's about
why do you want the connection what do
you want to do with the connection and
explain
why it'll be mutually beneficial right
don't just be like here's my business
card
if you if you know you know that they
would be in a beneficial position
you know sometimes i might just lay down
be like oh yes what do you do yeah
they'll tell me like oh no way i'm in
the same industry
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly well that's
organic right yeah all the time i'm
realizing
all according to no because
like it's because a lot of a lot of
weaves don't realize that one of the
most important skills you need to learn
when getting a job in any industry is
just social skills
no matter what you just gotta learn
social skills
i actually tutored like random people in
english in japan to develop social
skills
and like this this is this is this is
like like
should be inspiration for all of you if
this nervous wreck
can develop enough social skills to be
working in the industry and convince
[ __ ] japanese companies to form geeks
plus
there's hope for you as well okay
no amount of social anxiety is going to
stop you all right the first time i
called with you i was like wow
why she's so [ __ ] nervous yeah on the
phone i think you're like oh it's okay
don't be nervous and i'm like oh it's
just it's winter it's really cold
because my voice is that is the worst
thing to say though right just yeah
don't be nervous it's just gonna get the
more nervous i think i was like why are
you so nervous
yeah you said that and yeah
that i wanted to see what kind of
reaction melee would give i don't know
why i just wanted to see because
i just got a vibe that you would be in
real life first and animations
because i was like because we were
talking and then you're like well i i
don't know if we can um
what the [ __ ] wrong
because i remember my first business
meeting with you as well and like
whenever
madeline's negotiating it's like the
most hilarious thing
i think i've ever seen because when we
had the piece of paper out now yeah
it's like you know like you're i feel
like
it's so obvious if you don't like the
deal that's offered yeah
you're like it's like how how do i
say no without sounding like an [ __ ]
i know i know how she says this she says
oh
oh that's that's that's that's that's
the whenever you hear me lean saying
that
it's you immediately like oh it's not
good isn't it
no i was about to say you can write a
[ __ ] dictionary on your [ __ ] o's
and like which
which tone you say it in just
communicate something completely
different
to us as well like when i'm like when
i'm like when i'm texting you about like
a business deal and i'm like oh they
came back with this what do you think
and
you legitimately come back with oh
just like you pointed out i know exactly
what you mean i remember the story i
don't know if i've told this
i told you told you guys about the time
at promet was a guy no
no so when i was at the premiere of
primarity x there was a
i was sitting in the studio trigger
seats because a friend uh caramel yeah
got me into the studio trigger seats and
i was like well
it's [ __ ] cool yeah so i'm sitting on
the end of the studio trigger seats
right
promo is about to stop yeah it's obvious
it's studio tricks all the seats say
reserve for studio trigger yeah so i'm
sitting there and then this guy in like
a final fantasy
like cloud cosplay comes up to me and he
goes uh hey
uh do you work at trigger and i was like
uh no
do these guys do he's like and then he
goes and then he's i say that to him and
i was like oh i made a mistake
because then he's like oh uh hello and
then i'm like oh my god
of over me hello bear in mind he's he's
full costume [ __ ]
giant sword yeah yeah he's like how do i
get a job in studio trigger to this
japanese man who can't speak a word of
english yeah and he's like
uh
not like this literally i was like bro i
don't think this is the right time yeah
yeah i
asked that to them and they were visibly
confused i'm like bro i don't i don't
think this is
yeah he's like oh okay and i'm like what
the
[ __ ] what like with these kinds of
people what do they expect the answer to
be
be like oh yes here's my business card
called really [ __ ] wonker it's like
you were the right guy who asked
we were waiting for someone to be bold
enough to ask us at the promo
yeah so so advice right at your next
convention and you go
you see an industry guest don't do that
that's not how you get a job
he's in i couldn't believe it i mean i
don't think they're looking to hire when
they're at conventions
i don't know what person that's like the
hiring person wouldn't go to that event
anymore yeah
i think i mean if i ran an anime company
the last place i would go
to hire people is the kind of convention
but yeah it just
it just seems like the way to get hired
in japanese companies is just
first to be in japan right that's pretty
much in japan or like applied to
like us companies like church being like
outright and so like
not even i mean that's a little
aggressive asking right like that that
kind of way just doesn't work it's like
you've got to like
insert he's like you weren't even
cosplaying as a trigger character
you were cosplaying [ __ ] clowns full
like ryoko
kill like oh as you can see i am a fan
can i have a job so like our audience
knows
what we think about working in japanese
companies how is it for you
who actually works in a japanese company
for the industry different japanese
companies before the
anime accent animate the anime one
it's okay it's okay it won't hurt you
it's a microphone
i will kill you i don't know like if you
wanted me to say it's like exciting it's
nerd like nerdy no just be honest let's
be honest are the rumors true are
japanese companies
hell i'm joking don't look at me
yeah so like japan has like this
terminology where it's like it's black
or it's
white white is like they follow the
rules they treat their employees nice
and then black is like they overwork you
they ask you to work like i don't know
over time
but no like i got really lucky i think
the company i work with
i work for yeah really like very
aggressive about telling their employees
go home you know have a social life
and they like highly highly value
that so that's good what do you think
about the japanese like work life
schedule do you think like the as
someone who lives like i think it's on
average
crazy yeah they work on average 80 hours
a a week
yeah jesus christ 80 hours a week how is
like your work life schedule compared to
when you are
working outside of japan if you have any
comparisons
in well i only worked for an american
company in like san francisco
for a month before i quit and chase my
anime dreams
like can you really i guess based on
that one one month experience it's very
different like
in america i would just clock out and
leave that's that's yeah yeah yeah
here it's like you want to impress
your supervisor with good results and
sometimes to get those good results
i mean it doesn't necessarily make more
time but if you spend more time and do
more research well like lean's a hard
worker yeah
i have no i mean maybe and then the
polar opposite you got like the
scandinavian countries which are like
yeah
six hours a day is fine four days a week
yeah that seems good
but i mean it's been there's been plenty
of studies that prove that working more
doesn't necessarily mean more money i
mean there's studies to actually prove
they are the opposite of that which is
yeah yeah exactly i mean
i mean that's where the whole
controversy of like the whole zangyor
thing comes from right where like
employees of like traditional companies
are
almost forced like socially it's not a
rule in the company but they're almost
socially
bound to stay back over time to work i
don't think they should though not
because they need to do the work
but because as you said they want to
impress their supervisors right
kind yeah kind of uh but there are some
times like i think they really shouldn't
stay behind
even if they're not really working or
working because it really takes a toll
on their like mental health yeah for me
usually before an event
the month or month and a half i'm
actually working like really late like
11 pm or something because
crunch time type of thing yeah yeah and
i felt like
miserable during those times so i can
only imagine how miserable like
japanese people at japanese companies
that like do
they have their life i feel sorry yeah i
felt angry for no reason i'm like why am
i angry oh it's because i'm am i working
too much but i really loved what i did
even if you love what you do though you
when you get tired you you get cranky
i mean that's the same as us i mean we
we love our jobs it's always working
yeah but we're always working
and uh you know we never get a break but
even though we love what we do
there's times when i [ __ ] hate anime
you know you're just like
there are times where i'm just like i
don't want to work on this video
i just want to play games i know i know
watch porn or something like anything
else right to just get my mind off
that's what porn not even our porno
[Laughter]
what's a convention time like for you
then because
for us it's like especially ax it's busy
as hell but i've seen
people working in the industry working
[ __ ] over time when it comes to
convention season i i wonder as well
like expanding on that is like
how does it all work with like
industries in the conventions and like
you know i can only speak from like my
particular perspective
yeah i wouldn't expect you to be the
arbiter of knowledge on conventions
japanese companies i think they have to
prepare like
a lot more than u.s companies because we
have to like
consider people that don't speak english
coming over and
their first time exhibiting at an event
and the amount of time or
yeah the amount of time it takes to ship
something like if they're going to sell
something
at overseas at the convention shipping
it might be a problem
so it takes like a lot of time
to be fair though if i can say something
like i don't know if it's
just cuddle car well i i've noticed with
like any
booth that is run by a japanese company
the amount of stuff they have oh my god
kind of ridiculous
there's usually like a supervisor that's
watching another supervisor watching
other students yes
it's like the entire supply chain just
watching each other you've got like an
american like company booth right
you'll maybe sell like two two to five
for max yeah yeah
the cuddle car booth had like 60 people
yeah i remember going inside the capital
booth remember there's like 30 employees
yeah yeah
this is stupid the reason is like each
person like
even within cargo like say these are all
from the same series or no
not same series same publisher each
department has a different person in
charge and that person in charge needs
to be there
to like this feels like it's been like
what do they though yeah but this feels
like it should be this should have been
like
like coordinated something yeah right
that like this isn't needed just get
like one person to just like
kind of look over everything and then
once the event is done
it's really important for them to go
overseas because they're like
their mind is open open mind they become
open-minded
yeah yeah yeah sometimes how like the
american oh tacos are
yeah but the problem is half the
employees don't come out of the booth so
they don't even get to experience the
culture
they can see like or hear from outside
the booth like what items being sold the
most
and like take me so what do they think
of uh foreign conventions and foreign
culture then
from what are the ones from your
perspective i've heard they think it's
like wow
amazing like so different and like so
open
right compared to the fan otaku culture
here that's what i've heard from a lot
of japanese people
the fans here are really uptight like
for example i don't know
like comiket or anime events here you
can't go there and cosplay because you
would bring
shame to the event the neighboring
people oh yeah oh yeah
i actually my friends and i cosplayed at
comic hit like six years ago and we were
like
the top trending thing at that time on
on 2chan saying these three american
girls cosplaying as love live on the
train
and shame on me for not doing my
research right right hand
but but still chill yeah i had like
friends in america japanese friends in
america message me what are you guys
doing over there
you can't cosplay in the train like it's
not even it's not fun though i'd love to
see a cosplayer on there
follow us from station to station they
were like oh can you take that off
but we were only wearing the wig we were
wearing like i was wearing normal
clothes just the wigs so
you're not even allowed to wear a wig
yeah that's weird and then i told
well my friend told her she's like you
know we're only wearing the wig and like
no they know
from your hair what character you are
but like i understand if it's something
you know like gratuitous like
if you were all cosplaying is like
[ __ ] you know ryuko right yeah it's
like you know where it's like a little
more like yeah
yeah like yeah like a little more like
scandalous right like
it's love live you're in school uniform
yeah the only thing that separates you
from like a regular school girl
is just the wig yeah but to be fair like
they want to protect this culture they
want to keep having these events
they're not it's
would be on the train and they see some
crazy
isn't that fun though yeah but they make
your life up a little bit
but also like anime otaku's in japan
aren't viewed in like a positive light
i don't think they necessarily are in
the west
i don't feel like there's as bad as
stigma compared to what it is here
because i think you're like sweaty and
i mean i am but like
you're just so weird you watch like the
weird stuff on the internet my life's
not even that weird
i i rocked up on the london underground
in the maid outfit
like just did it like 40-minute commute
hell yeah yeah
everyone loves it they're like all
laughing or giggling but they would be
like what are you cosplaying or
dressing up as yeah yeah i'd get like
heckled from the other side of the thing
and then like you know it's just good
fun i don't know i thought it was funny
but obviously i guess it's such a weird
double standard though isn't it where
it's like you know
like anime loving otakus are like ew
sweaty gross and then meanwhile if
there's a guy rocking up with like
full-on like you know idol
[ __ ] and just like oh he just really
likes idols it's like
it's like no he's just a sweaty like a
lot of people think it's gross like
every time i told like japanese people
like
like oh i'm i'm an otaku they're like no
you're not you don't look like a
what is it and it's like really like how
dare you insult my people
yeah yeah like what's what's what are
they expecting otaku to look like where
it's like you're [ __ ] 300 pounds yeah
i think it's like how weeaboo the word
weeaboo used to be
seen like 10 years ago in our community
where who who would like identify
themselves as a weeaboo
that's like cringy cringy like that's
like a cringy person nobody wants to
know right
right because because the stereotypical
like otaku in japan
like you don't see people like that
anymore no no there's like there's like
people who like anime and that's just
like
normalized here like 20 year old girls
have like the ita bags
yeah yeah yeah i love 2d boys
and everyone loves jojo's everyone
that's like
that's like this man it's almost like
the chichi that's like the chichi right
did you just wear jojo merch to like a
business meeting
and everything feels so good yeah you'll
get like a 50 year old businessman can't
you be like i love jojo's
dude i [ __ ] i i was buying manga like
my local bookstore and i was wearing one
of the glam jojo shirts yeah the guy
like stopped like
putting in the books and he's like
where'd you get that shirt
and i was like oh glam and he's like
that looks sick dude he just high-fives
me and i'm like
i've never had this experience in japan
obviously this is before the pandemic
right social distance but like
and everyone clapped in the store
applauded joey
congratulations and then they played the
jojo opening and i left
those themed
dating in japan video i mentioned like
oh yeah i just openly said i was an
otaku and then i was like why are people
getting all worked up about it and then
i got loads of comments they're like
it means a bad thing in japan and i was
like yeah i know i just don't care like
yeah if i can normalize it i can help to
get there
yeah if someone wasn't seen in a
negative way that's their baroque
exactly
yeah most most of the people that i told
it to you didn't give a [ __ ] yeah go mad
to conventions though one thing i've
always been curious about is how do you
guys like pick the guests
to like bring over and showcase to
people is there like a process behind
that or
for my company there was at the time
when i was
like the event person in shock in charge
of events
um we would look first at the sales
right like oh what's trending
what's like the top selling manga or
light novel the top ten
and then i just contacted them yeah
yeah and because i'm in book walker and
book walkers like has really close ties
to all different kinds of publishers
yeah um i guess we're able to ask
them yeah yeah i mean yeah because that
makes sense because i
because i've done so many like creator
panels yeah especially at ax with bulk
walker
i did it with like domaci goblin slayer
and every time i remember like every
time one of those panels finish
it's always one person who comes up to
me for some reason of all people and
it's like
hey next year can you get uh the author
of this
uh light novel that'd be really cool did
you ever get people who thought you were
the author of something
yeah yeah i had that yeah i've had that
really yeah someone came up to my thing
this
okay this is back when uh the 93 was
still a thing oh yeah
yeah some some guy like like 13 year old
boy came up to me i'm like that's weird
why is there a guy in my line
so he comes up to me he's like oh yeah
yeah he took took a photo did the
signings like you're the author of
goblin slayer right
no kidding i was like no because we had
autographs at our booth
he was like you're the author of goblins
saying like do you look like japanese
like what
no no i don't get a lot of you're the
author but i always get a lot of like
you're the guy who does the official
translations translated like
what the author was saying yeah yeah
yeah you must and yeah i had a i
remember i had a guy just being like um
when's like uh like volume three of
goblins like gonna get translated
like i [ __ ] know she's
just been like yeah actually tomorrow
yeah i'm working on it right now
actually don't worry it's coming soon
if you just left me alone it would have
been done yeah no but again yeah but i
get so many people just being like hey
can you bring on
this creator or like this author i'm
just like
don't ask me i'm just i'm just hosting
it anime departments of like certain
companies
they usually bring guests uh of
like say directors or whatever of
whatever anime is coming out that season
and they have a premiere
and the author or director comes to
promote the premiere so not necessarily
it's like trending it's basically just
all marketing then
yes this is the way i see it yeah so
it's all data it's all marketing
it's all data and marketing because i
always wondered ax must be really
expensive to like put up all the like
the
the booth the staff the marketing is it
like i mean obviously it must be worth
it right like is the return on
investment like huge there
i mean they're not really looking for
sales directly
right i think it's just looking for
presents because if you don't have a
presence it's like not being at e3
you know what i mean i guess even
companies now are like questioning if e3
is worth it yeah
i mean like i mean sony wasn't at e3 the
year before i think and that was like
massive news because that was like a
massive statement being like hey
we don't [ __ ] need e3 you know we're
[ __ ] sony
i wonder if that would be a thing with
that like ax when the company's like oh
we don't really need ax anymore right a
lot of
uh companies though or japanese
companies are bringing their own guests
instead of the guest of honor thing yeah
because i i feel like right now with and
with like anime growing so much in the
west i think there is a
big like a big um like there's more eyes
at ax
now yeah so like if you're not there
then that's that's like
that's like a missed opportunity more
than hey this is e3 you know i mean this
is already established press
too yeah a lot of news sites are all at
this event so they could arrange
interviews or whatever that could
promote it
so going back 900 million topics ago
yeah yeah with how we started it piracy
kiss anime going down
like what are our final thoughts like i
guess what are our like final thoughts
on pirates and anime because we we've
thrown around a bunch of like different
this this this episode is turned into
like
an anime industry episode as a whole
yeah i think
wrapping up the piracy debates i mean
i i don't want to get any companies that
never want to work with us
generally piracy bad i think we can all
agree paris is not good
but like everything in life there is no
you know sometimes it's a necessary evil
you know
right it's not always clear-cut and i
think in until people
you know in the positions of uh you know
authority most of the time or
who in the industry recognize that there
might be in some cases you know it's all
right
it's much of a service problem as it is
a community problem right because
like yeah of course people will say like
oh you know
the only reason these piracy sites are
thriving is because these legal sites
aren't doing the job
that these piracy sites are covering but
then at the same time a lot of the
community is like
nah dude let's just use the piracy i
don't think you need to justify or say
like shame people either no yeah no
definitely not
and i think there's one thing one last
point i want to make about about the
service thing
where no matter what like i don't think
legal sites will
ever get to a point when they can fully
compete with piracy i mean there's never
going to be
one company that has all the shows or
has like every
every show in existence and even though
every company is trying their best
every company's trying their best but i
don't think we'll ever get to a point
where
we're gonna get like a legal kiss anime
you know what i mean
or a legal whatever site and i think
recognizing that
it is an uneven playing field and you
know
legal companies aren't perfect but in my
eyes i give them a bit of leeway if
all i'm look all i look for is if i can
just play my [ __ ]
anime or my chromecast without any
worries and that's pretty much
all like all i need for like my five
dollar subscription
yeah i gladly i paid for control for
years yeah yeah yeah
and i just like if we could just stop
the argument being like okay you're
either on one side or the other either
with us or against us
um i think there's a healthy middle
ground for people to be
to be had yeah also who the [ __ ] cares
let's be honest
like i'm gonna pay i'm gonna pay for it
and if you don't want to i don't
particularly yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
there's enough people like me
who have disposable income and can
afford to do so and are willing to do so
that at the end of the day
who [ __ ] cares most these people who
are like on their high horse
shouting people not to pirate you're
shouting at like 12 year old kids who
don't know any better let's be honest
that's what the
[ __ ] half of twitter is who gives a
[ __ ] that's i
i'll just keep paying i don't care
that's like going to the lower class and
being like you can't afford balenciaga
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
it's like yeah maybe some people just
can't and you mean you're buying
knock-off valencia yeah what the [ __ ]
you you're not supporting the fashion
industry because of that
it's like yeah just just do you man and
just like
like none of us really care that much i
don't think we're not like activists pay
for your anime legally
cool yeah you pay money illegally cool
my philosophy
has has and always has been just just do
what you can you know
everyone's situation is different
everyone's got a different reason or is
in a different position in life just do
what you can and do what you feel like
whatever be a bully
don't be a bully just don't be a dick
don't be a dick don't don't be a dick
and
just like don't try to take advantage of
the system and
yeah that's that's pretty that's pretty
much my opinion
please konami stop making pachinko
machines i beg of you make anything but
pachinko and check out bulk walker
so that's the bottom line yeah yeah well
you know what you can also check out
patreon like these lovely people look at
these lovely names look at all these
memories
yeah they support the show
i like him i like him or her big thank
you to today's sponsor as well eg anime
store yeah yeah very much
also you can go check out our subreddit
also check out our twitter all the links
as always is in the description below
yeah monkey brain gang rise up
unfortunately i don't think you can
check out maylyn she doesn't she's she's
do you have any social media you want a
shout out or anything like maelyn
it's cringy so no no no no
but again check out book walker instead
yeah do you run the twitter account for
that still
no i stopped like last year or something
okay okay so yeah
that's why the memes became less fire
yeah
the last thing i posted was was it inner
species reviewers
but yeah thank you very much for coming
on for coming on man i know
there was a lot of limited things you
could not talk about
especially still working on the industry
but we very much appreciate you business
man yeah that's that's just business
yeah yeah i'm sure people will be mad
that you didn't get to talk as much as
us but
you know we we talk our asses off um if
i talk too much i might say something
illegal
just kidding yeah if you guys want more
mailing don't worry there'll be plenty
of melina's shouting at meleen
yeah she'll always she'll always be
behind there somewhere you know yeah
behind the camera behind the camera
running the secret mastermind behind
this show
thank you very much for coming on and
shining more lights on the industry
thank you for having me
yeah saying saying what you can say
about
what goes on behind the scenes because i
know i know there's a lot of like eyes
and you don't want to get fired or
anything like that i think a lot of
people though will like appreciate your
opinions
yeah especially like with the whole like
you know getting a job in japan
shout out to craigslist shout out to
craigslist craigslist
it doesn't even sponsor people i think
hey hey craigslist
except except when there are cockroaches
in the fridge
i've seen too much please don't we
should not be supporting this
gave you your visa
anyway thank you very much for watching
today we've been trash taste and the
boys and
we've been mailing or melin's been there
and we'll see you guys next time bye
you